The Joe Rogan experience podcast,
whenever,
whenever you talked to a rapper or any
dude who has like a name like kid cuddy,
you'd never know.
Am I supposed to call you kid?
I'm immortal technique comes on the
podcast all the time.
To this day,
I don't know what to call that dude.
I love it.
He's cool as fuck.
I love talking to them,
but I never know what to call them.
Don't call them tech comm.
A mortal Mr.
Technique.
So I had to ask you before this podcast
started,
I said,
do I refer to you as kid cuddy or do I
call you Scott?
I introduced myself to other human
beings with my government name Scott.
I don't walk up and say goodbye,
but no.
Like I get Mr cuddy sometime and that's
a little weird.
It makes me sound like a stripper or
something.
Mr [inaudible].
Mr Cuddy,
Mr Kelly's cool.
If it's like a chick.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's a.
it's.
It's a weird.
There's not a whole lot of white dudes
who ever pulled off the like the
nickname,
like carrot top weird Al Right.
Weird.
I was always weird.
Al.
It's always weird.
Al yankovIc.
No.
Hi,
I'm al yankovic.
It's weird.
al right.
P dot p dot diddy,
puff daddy,
prince,
whatever.
A lot of black guys pulled it off.
I mean just.
You just keep going forever,
but there's a small handful of white
people ever pulled off the nickname.
Okay.
I would say you're going to talk about
captain kirk,
captain and captain into neil.
The kid goes deep into the 19 seventies
drAwer,
the captain to neil.
What?
How.
That's a terrible band from back waY
back in the day.
Terrible by today's standards,
but back in the day,
people love them.
Do you remember the captain into.
You know,
I don't remember what they sang.
I shouldn't even say that terrible
because I'm being a dick because I
don't.
I doN't remember any of their songs.
Probably sitting tHere like,
I believe one of them is dead captain.
I think one of them got some serious
anorexia through.
I think the woman got serious.
I might be mixing my stories up from 19
seventies bands that I barely pay
attention to,
but you want to talk about the people
that have got some fucking stories.
You know,
the people that that grew up during the
sixties and were like famous during the
seventies.
Yeah.
Those are,
that's a strange little slice of
americAn life right there.
You could imagine it was just a whole
nother way of living,
you know?
I think there was a lot more
communication amongst human beings.
Yeah,
for sure.
Like just,
you know,
just casual conversation.
It wasn't like weird.
Nowadays if you even just say hi to
someone walking down the street,
it's like,
what the fuck?
Being polite.
LIke what the fuck did you say to me?
Well,
I think two things are going on.
One,
people are just nervous because there's
a lot of new stories about terrible
things have happened over world.
Like most of whAt you get in the news is
terrible things,
so people always woRried about terrible
things when they meet strangers and then
to everybody's fucking texting and
emailing and the amount of time you
spend.
Person a person has probably been
greatly.
Yeah,
for sure.
AnD,
and,
and um,
support,
you know,
there's healthy dose.
They'll probably just put up
picture the capital.
Now we know.
I mean,
one of them love buddy miles.
He has one of those caps and routes all
the time.
That's a good cap.
Just letting everybody know that you
liked to party.
Miles teller,
miles teller.
He wills,
he wears a cap like that all the time.
That's one of those things.
If you walk around with a captain's hat
on and you're like a sober guy,
you're an asshole.
No parties.
He gets it in one of those dudes doesn't
smoke weed.
Doesn't drink.
I don't do toll straight.
I'd be wearing like a captain's hat.
You're a fucking idiot.
But there's something if you're like
some hunter s thompson do with captain
tat on your,
on while you got a bottle of whiskey in
one hand,
a bottle of vodka.
The other that's.
I want to talk to that dude for real.
you know,
I'm hanging out with him.
Yeah.
There's certain outfits that you allowed
to wear if you get fucked up like the
way stan hope tresses,
like if stan hope was like a sober guy
that he can pull off that outfit.
He's hammered all the time.
So he was wearing this bright checkered
leisure suit or whatever he wears.
Yeah.
Every city he goes to a thrift store and
tries to find the most shittiest,
I guess,
suit you can pop.
Oh,
sweet stuff that doesn't fit them all
the time.
It's like barely fits him.
He's awesome dude.
You're a,
you're a young man and you're doing very
well.
Everything is going well for you.
This is A trying time in your life.
Yeah,
man.
I'm trying.
What's it like to be kid cuddy?
Uh,
it's um,
it's cool man.
I feel like it's intrusive.
No,
no.
I mean,
um,
you know,
it's nothing too spectacular.
I'm mostly like trying to stay creative
and uh,
hang around family a lot,
get family time and when my mom and my
daughter and so,
like my life is split between that and
you know,
creating,
it's a good balance.
I found the balance now at 30.
At 32,
you're living the dream.
Yeah,
it's cool,
man.
I can't complain.
You know,
the days I complained,
I realize I can't complain.
You definitely can't complain.
No,
I mean to be a professional entertainer
is probably the luckiest job of all
time.
Like you made it.
Well,
it's really deeper than that.
I think that just have a fan base,
you know,
that supportive is the real ultimate
blessing because you know,
guys get record deals all the time,
you know,
some of their music and shit,
but then it's just like,
you know,
but then when you have,
you have a lot of artists that come and
you know,
ended up having like a grassroots
following and they have a fan base that
rides with them then entire career.
That's,
that's man,
that's a,
that's a blessing on top of a blessing.
You never know because today's audience,
you know,
these kids like you one minute,
they hate you the next,
like you want me to hit your next and to
have a fan base in that
type of climate and it's awesome.
Yeah,
that is the thing that it used to be
like if you were a rapper or any kind of
entertainer,
you were only as good if you're a
comedian,
you're only as good as the people got to
see you out there.
LIke it was really difficult to,
to build a fan base if you weren't on
something,
if you weren't on a television show of
your warrant,
you know,
a weekly regular guests length the
tonight show or something like that.
It was really hard for someone like
build a fan base.
But today because of the internet,
rappers,
singers,
musicians,
I mean everybody,
comedians,
all,
they can kind of keep tabs and just
communicate with people directly.
Yeah.
And I feel like I caught him was at the
beginning,
the early stages of that wave of just
know another way for people to find
music online,
new artists,
you know,
music that you probably wouldn't hear on
the radio stuff.
That's quality,
quality,
you know,
music and now you know,
things are way more advanced.
Even since when I started,
you know,
when I dropped dead at night,
that was 2007.
I think the only platform at that time
that I had at my disposal to upload
music was my space and that was
literally how the world discovered my
voice,
you know,
through my space music page.
And how did my space dropped the ball so
hard had the world by the balls.
They had everybody.
I think,
um,
you know,
everybody I don't think,
I don't even think they've fallen off
like that.
I just think that there's just so much.
There's just so much out there.
There's definitely,
there's an over abundance of,
you know,
this,
like for every facebook there's five
more other facebook's.
Well there's always new ones coming out
too.
It's got to be hard to figure out a new
thing though.
Like what's the new things that involve
video?
What's going to be the new thing?
Memes and emojis.
I think it's just a combination of
everything just like,
well you,
it's a one stop shop to just anything
that you can dick around on the internet
with.
It's possible through this
app,
you know,
probably.
Right.
And I think it's also,
have you seen that new thing that a
unbox therapy did a video on?
Oh my god.
Louis from unbox therapy did this video
of this new iron man tech.
If you go to his page,
go to unbox therapy.
Iron man for real.
I think it's called as a youtube video
that he put up.
It's insane to do.
You're putting on these gloves.
Are these goggles rather that cover your
cover,
your eyes sort of oculus rift style.
but you see everything.
I would see you clearly.
But in front of you there's like icons
and things that I can move around.
I can open things and close them.
And you do it all with hand gestures.
So like as I'm looking at you,
if I have these glock,
these goggles on,
I'd be looking at you and I'd see these
floating geometric objects like boxes,
circles and you can open them up and
close them and move them around and they
stay places like minority report style.
Oh she remembers doing that on a screen.
But you're going to be able to do it
like in the air,
like when tony stark put that helmet on
it,
that's going to be like reality and in
his
words and louis' words,
he said,
this guy wants to make the world the
desktop.
The world is your screens while it's
takeaway screens and the screens are
going to be the world.
You put this thing on and you just see
through it and there's no more screens
anymore.
Everything you do,
you do through this.
This is his ultimate goal.
Now there's the like the glasses look
all like fucking gnarly,
like some super visor,
virtual reality them,
they're right up there.
They're pretty big right now.
But so was the first phone.
Remember those home telephones,
those giant boxes?
They used to have to crank call people
up and needs to fucking put cables into
holes and shit.
You remember all that.
That was what a,
that was an old phone used to be like,
but you know what,
this type of technology you wouldn't
want,
you know,
walking down the street or like on you
everyday that easily to access.
I mean,
people wouldn't,
you know what I mean,
like it's kind of like not that weird
that it's kind of big and something that
you gotta like be stationary with at
home.
That's actually saves,
saves a world in some small way for a
few years.
You met?
Yeah.
Until like,
you know,
apple figures it out to have it on your
phone or something.
But they're gOnna they're gonna make it
in like a google glass form for sure.
Well the google glasses is like just a
smaller version of that.
yeah.
So you can't,
you can't,
you swIpe and stuff,
but you can't really manipulate the
image in real time.
Have you played with it at all?
Yeah,
I got one.
One,
it's a,
you know,
it's cool.
It was,
I mean I'm not gonna.
I went out in the streets a couple times
and I really noticed.
I actually tweeted about this,
tweeted about it because it was so funny
to me.
My experience going on public with
google glasses.
People just really thought that I was
either taking a picture of them are
filming them and that when people were
really concerned because there's no
like,
recording lie and you could tell it,
there's a lens there,
you know,
and especially once you miss people ask
you what it is and you say google glass,
people have heard about it.
They're like,
are you filming me?
And I thought it was interesting,
you know,
because this is something that like,
you might see a celebrity,
you know,
freak out beCause they're getting
photographed or filmed trying to,
you Know,
live their lives and do something with
their families and try to have some
privacy and then the public really
doesn't understand why they might freak
out and why that might be intrusive,
but it's,
it's a funny twist for me to walk in a
place and all of a sudden someone's
like,
are you filming me?
Whoa,
whoa.
Like,
what are you doing this?
It's like,
no,
I'm not filming a random person that's
intrusive because I understand that
that's intrusive,
but it is a potential option for the
future.
That's what's weird about it,
but it just,
it was,
it was interesting to just see like that
was besides people being like,
oh,
it's cool,
can I try it?
It was just like,
are you filming me?
Like,
are you filming mary taking a picture at
home?
I supposed to know that you're telling
me the truth,
you kNow,
because you could just be lying and then
even if I take it off it cuts off so
it's not like you could see what I'm
seeing when I'm doing it.
You know,
They have little cameras,
members stand hope had that fox show way
back then they had little cameras that
would go on glasses like in the eyes,
the eyebrow part of a glass and he put
his glasses on and he would walk into
some and do these pranks
and they would.
The film was good enough to put on
television and that was a long time ago.
Yeah,
I mean you could film stuff and put it
up on your twitter through the google
glass and the photos are pretty quality
of that in a couple of times.
Oh wow.
It's going to get crazier than that
right there.
It's gonna.
Get to some point where you're going to
be able to put contact lenses on or
something,
you know,
but I don't know.
I mean that's,
that's wild shit with the contact lenses
and they all have their own.
they get charged with solar power
because your eyes are always open.
Yeah.
Constant solar energy.
Right?
Technology in my eye though,
I don't know if I want to.
Yeah,
I definitely don't want to right now,
but if the problem is everybody has it
and it's awesome,
you know,
I mean I would have always been tied to
a phone just because it's so dope.
Like to have a phone.
That's an incredible thing.
I'd rather have a cyborg arm before I
have a contact,
a cyborg arm.
You know what I mean?
But when you see the real thing about
the sidebar ground,
that really freaks me out.
This is no bullshit.
It really does kind of freak me out.
I,
we watched this video once of a dude
from Australia.
They got his arm and his leg bid off.
I think I've seen that exact shit.
It's amazing,
so this guy had no army,
no leg,
but he walked without a limp and his
hands moved around and didn't move as
good.
I mean it probably couldN't play piano
or something like that,
but move pretty god damn good.
A lot better than the old ones that came
With the hook style old ones and I was
thinking like this guy is still a
person,
100 percent human,
but he has an artificial arm and an
artificial leg.
Like what if,
what if the shark bit everything but his
head and they took his head and they put
it on an artificial body.
What would that be?
THat is that still a person.
I guess it's a person because you got a
person's head,
but what if they said,
listen man,
this transfer of your head to this
artificial body is not working that
good.
Your body's rejecTing it.
You're head's rejecting the body,
but the good news is we can completely
duplicate your brain and put it in this
artificial head.
So to be like your brain,
except better because it's never going
to get old.
It's not going to rot away like,
well,
are you a person then?
No,
because I think your soul is gone.
At that point.
I would like to believe that too,
but imagine if that's how people were
essentially created in the first place.
Just what if they slow improvements,
what if they go,
okay,
we're going to take a snapshot of your
brain right now because we're going to
transfer it to this new body,
so anything after this point,
you know you're not going to remember.
So then in for like 10 minutes before
they pulled the plug on this body,
you can just abuse the person that death
or even your body,
not the existential angst
dying and having no soul.
You're thinking about playing with
someone ball
and you're 40.
Congratulations.
Speaking of cameras,
joe,
I just got one added to my car so it
records everything.
Now that my car does and it does it on
gps and then when you watch it on your
computer,
it shows real time.
Google maps and a three 60 view almost
of your car,
your front.
And that's pretty interesting.
Yeah,
it's called roadhog hawk,
hawk road hockey,
and what it does is you just put a
memory card in there and it constantly
records.
Where are the cameras?
The cameras like this little box,
it looks like a baby radar detector that
you just put a underneath your,
uh,
behind your rear view mirror.
So you just put on the windshield right
there and you have to run power.
I just plug mine into my cigarette
lighter and it connects to gps and it
records on a memory card.
Where's the cameras?
The camera has a wide angle lens so it
gets everything in your car,
the front of your car and it also gets
sound and it attracts everything because
I was just tired of driving around
hollywood,
like going to the comedy store every
night and then,
and then like almost getting in car
accidents,
crazy crack heads,
like jumping in the street,
like all this shit happening all the
time,
like something's going to happen soon,
you know,
and I don't have this polluted.
People have to see this when,
you know,
in Russia,
that's when they had those,
uh,
those mediators,
they caught those.
That's how they caught him.
They caught him because those people
have dash cams because apparently I'm
like fraud and like that kind of shit
like accident of fraud,
like super common in Russia.
Like they pull shady moves all the time.
So a lot of people have those little
cameras on the dash to make sure that
they could resolve disputes,
you know,
like there was a thing that was going
around in California for a while where
people were suing people.
They would get an accent on purpose.
A bunch of people die from it.
They'd get on the highway,
get in front of you and slam on the
brakes.
So he slammed into him and this one dude
who was an illegal alien,
so it was like all the republicans were
up in arms when he's the only one
illegal.
Alien does something shady.
Everybody freaks the fuck out.
But this student done it a couple of
times.
He'd done it a couple of times and that
was his move.
That's way it made a lot of money just
getting in front of people,
slam on the crazy.
Yeah,
but that's a risky fucking shit where
you ain't got nothing to lose.
It's like fuck it.
Yeah,
I guess it's just they're playing the
lottery and the promise land just very,
very strange.
That's the item that
item c right there is where you put the
memory card in
and it's not that big.
No,
it is kinda like a.
It's hard to tell perspective wise,
it's like a cell phone size basically
and he just like,
I can't even barely even see my mindset
high hidden behind my mirror,
like a disposable camera.
It was probably the best way to describe
it.
It's like a disposable camera.
What's cool?
It does like a dvr loop,
like would they like a security
companies do or where they have to film
everything,
like a jewelry store or something.
It just,
when it gets to the end of the memory
card,
it just goes back to the beginning.
Unless you pull it out and save the
files.
Records over records,
everything over and over and over,
long before people start making porn
with those.
I know,
but you know what it's also great.
Automatically turns on,
so if you give your car to the valet or
something,
you could hear what they're doing to
turn it around.
That's what I'm getting at.
That's all right.
SenD me link valet
porn.
Valets.
Blowing each other in your car won't get
onto your car.
You're like,
what the hell?
But I'm reviewing it right now.
I have a review.
What site now do you ever review?
Website?
Java lamps.com.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah,
it's good.
Do you.
You stopped doing that for awhile?
Yeah,
I lost my amazon account.
Wow.
How does that work,
man?
Did you ever try to get it back?
Yeah.
I tried three times with my llc,
a social security number or whatever the
business id number tried with them,
so it was completely away from me.
I tried everything and finally they just
let me through because of this java
lamps thing.
TheY did let you through.
They just finally did after about four
years of not letting me do it.
Just because you changed the name of
your website?
I guess so website and everything.
I don't know how annoying.
Yeah.
It seems like there was a weird thing.
It was like they're upset at you because
you're connected to porn.
Right?
Porn stars on desk squad meticulous.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with porn stars.
Nothing.
You just don't.
They sell porn.
I mean if you go to amazon.com,
don't they sell porn?
Yeah.
VIbrators.
They sell hitachi's.
By the way,
did you see ms dot martinez,
our friend missy.
I killed tony with us a lot of times she
was on tmz because her hitachi blew up
in her pussy.
No,
really blow up in airports.
You blow it up in her pussy and make it
the equivalent to the mexican dudes
slammed on his brakes on the highway.
It was.
Was it the vibrator equivalent?
What happened?
Is it to the breaking crash.
What happened is it starts sparking in
flames and smoke starts coming.
Footage.
Did she start screaming?
Yeah.
The pussies that good.
That's why it's sparking.
No.
There's the hitachi though,
and what's weird is that this is not
new.
There's nothing new about this.
If you look online,
there's tons of hitachi's blowing up and
a porn stars.
Yeah,
because it's the only vibrator that you
plug into a wall,
so it's like it's like the dumbest
because it's really for your back
because it's supposed to be high
powered,
but like girls are getting so numbed
down there that they're using these
hitachi's,
these high powered ones that just shave
off my.
Oh my god.
They take things to the next level.
Just like when we were talking about
bodybuilders have like the 19 sixties in
comparison to the bodybuilders it today.
I think it's the same way with like the
way girls beat on their pussies.
Absolutely embedded in the old days.
Just a little spit and defenders need
anything that didn't need anything.
Their vaginas.
We're super sensitive technology.
Fuck things up.
Soda doesn't fuck things up for us
apparently if you don't.
If you don't have a for skin,
the head of your dick,
it's like kinda just abused.
So it's bouncing around inside your
underwear and like having a force,
getting the reason why men are upset
that they're not just the fact that it's
ritual,
genital mutilation,
that doesn't make any sense,
but also that it kills the sensitivity
in your dick.
Yeah.
but yeah,
I mean that's great.
That's great.
You like you're addicted.
Look like clint eastwood and not like
fucking ryan seacrest or somethIng.
That doesn't make any sense because
you're beating the tip of your dick up.
I mean if you look at your data,
it looks like you're beating up your
dick and it looks like clinics with
today talking about clint eastwood from
the fucking outlaw josey wales.
You're talking spaghettI westerns.
I'm talking about porch one.
The handsome clinics would not the crazy
looking old man.
Obama.
He talked to obama.
That was.
Do you remember?
Do you remember that shit that he did on
tv where you saddled bama down?
No,
you didn't see.
Watch It.
We'll pull this out dude.
Yeah,
we'll pull it up.
This was recent.
oh my god.
It was general presidential elections
pretended to sit obama down onstage and
improv.
It didn't have anything pointing to say,
but improv'd it.
It was so incredibly disrespectful.
It was so.
He was just pretending to have a
conversation with sat him down below
him.
He didn't just have a conversation.
He wasn't like pertaining to have a
conversation with obama where they're
looking eye to eye like men.
No,
he sat him down in a chair and started.
It was the strangest fucking thing ever.
This is it here.
yeah,
yeah.
He was having that thing and they were
talking about hope and change and they
were talking about yes we can.
And,
and it was dark and outdoors and it was
nice and people are lighting candles and
they were saying,
I just thought this is great.
I mean everybody's crying.
Oprah was crying.
I was even crying.
And then finally I haven't cried that
hard since I found out that there's 23
million unemployed people in this
country.
Well,
he sat them down here.
Yeah.
To cry for discretion.
National.
I'm home tomorrow morning.
No,
you got to back it up because that's the
chair pushing down in the chair.
You were running for election.
No,
no,
back it uP a little bit more now.
It may be time for somebody else to come
along and solve the problem.
So mr.
President,
how do you,
how do you handle a,
how do you handle promises that you've
made when you were running for election
and how do you handle,
how do you handle that?
I mean,
what do you say to people do.
You could just,
uh,
you know,
I know people,
uh,
people were wondering,
you don't,
but I know even some of the people in
your own party who were very
disappointed we did,
didn't close gitmo and I thought,
well I think get cash at closing gitmo.
Why close that?
We spent so much money on it.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I thought maybe it's an excuse a,
what do you mean shut up?
I thought it was just because somebody
has
you.
Otherwise the whole thing worse.
Worse.
I remembered,
I remembered it being bad,
but holy shit,
I like how cnn like jumped to like the
mtv camera where were there in the
audience and saw shaky,
like to try to make it more like
entertaining him talking to him.
So ridiculous.
What the hell is he doing?
He's being an old dude.
That's what he's doing.
Being an old republican dude.
Get all crusty,
conservative.
Not like then they don't like the youth.
The young of America.
Like yourself to that movie.
Didn't he just do that movie though?
Uh,
what was it a.
Well,
he's like the movie and you were just
talking about about the immigrant pissed
about people being on this porch.
Yeah,
I,
no,
it was named after,
but no,
el camino is el camino because he knows
the grant.
You know the black keys,
the black keys have a cdl
called el camino?
Don't think so.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
El torito,
whatever it was outscored torino grand
screener.
No,
I had a friend whose girlfriend had one
of those cars
way back in the day.
That was a goofy ass car that was back
in America.
Just made these houses on wheels.
They made a living room.
They just drove around and this big old
fucking crazy american cars,
man.
Yeah.
That was a movie about what it was like
about immigrants,
wasn't it?
I don't know if it was people moving in
his neighborhood.
I just remember seeing that in the
preview,
seeing really pissed about kids being on
his porch yet.
But I mean I was sold.
I mean I wanted to see it.
I just never got around to it.
Maybe I'll check it out.
I think you've got better shit to do
with being pissed about people being on
phone.
He had a shotgun in his hand to.
Do you remember when clinics.
We did a reality show.
A lot of people don't know that clinics,
which wife was on a reality show before
we got divorced.
He divorced her,
but she was on a reality show and it was
like some knucklehead chose ridiculous,
but he was.
He on episodes.
Don't remember if he was on.
I never watched it,
but yeah,
it's one of those things where like the
wife wanted to do it and he was like,
oh,
okay.
He finds himself with some ridiculous
situation.
Have you ever met him?
No.
I always see him in burbank because I
think he has a studio at warner
brothers,
so he's always walking on the sidewalk
out there and it's weird just driving by
glenn did.
That guy gets a path from for life for
me,
for the unforgiven that I think it's the
greatest cowboy movie of all time.
Oh yeah.
That shit was like,
it was so realistic,
so dope.
That was such a good,
scary ass cowboy movie.
That was clint eastwood.
Its finest,
you know,
I just love how he's just like,
I don't live like that no more.
No movies.
Just like I'm not that guy.
I love it.
And then they just dragged him in.
Spoiler alert.
Oh yeah.
That's not tell him,
but he's like one of those dudes that
becomes this old guy and then he becomes
like super duper conservative.
You know?
There's a bunch of those guys like
cosby's a guy like that.
He's like super duper conservative now,
jon voight.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean that movie though is one of,
is one of my favorites,
especially morgan freeman to one of my
favorite morgan freeman movie.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah man,
that was just a perfect movie.
Yeah,
just the way the women.
I don't want to give away the ending,
but the way it all goes down so much
more likely than most of those stupid
shoot 'em up movies that was much more
probably like what,
how the way people would behave.
Oh yeah.
It was.
And it ended up getting messy in there,
but I like how I kind of just started
off like real chill and you kinda just,
you know,
okay,
yeah,
I'm here.
Yeah.
That was a fascinating look at the old
west.
I was like,
it's almost like he did it,
like he did all those westerns back in
the day,
like the good,
the bad,
and the ugly and fun movies.
But they weren't super realistic,
you know,
and I think as he got older,
I mean I'm just speculating,
but he wanted to do one more.
That really got it right,
like the way they make movies today as
opposed to way they made movies back in
like high plains drifter days.
Did you see true grit?
Yeah,
I saw both.
I saw the old one,
the new one.
It was not bad.
I knew what it was.
Not bad.
It was not a bad mood.
I liked it.
It's just whenever you have a movie
where you're redoing an old movie,
people are harsh,
you know?
I mean,
but,
you know,
I feel like it kind of brought some of
that realness that,
you know,
unforgiven hand.
Yeah,
it definitely did.
there was doubt.
I mean,
it was a good movie for sure.
There was a lot of fun shit going on
that movie.
But goddamn man,
remaking a john wayne movies hard.
Uh,
uh.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
hollywood,
they do what they can.
I mean,
it wasn't like,
you know,
most of the shit that comes out that
gives me gurgitate.
It just kind of be hard to make movies,
man.
You know,
one of the beautiful things about,
do you write all your own lyrics?
Yes.
Thank god.
I'm blessed with that ability,
you know,
a lot of guys don't see.
Think of that.
Just think of,
think of that like how happy you are
that you write on your shit and imagine
this,
you're a one man situation.
You know,
if you want the kid cuddy experience,
you only go through one door.
There's no one else there so they'd go
to you,
but you don't have to worry about the
producer getting along with director,
get along with the actor.
The network has notes of studIo rather
has notes about the script,
the screenwriter or wants to change this
and the actor wants to improv that.
You're managing it out with the fucking
makeup lady who's fucking the
hairdresser.
Everybody's doing blow after the sets
closed down.
It's craziness,
man.
Making the movies go down that in music
though too,
you know,
my career is just purely my vision and
stuff.
so it's a different,
it's a little unorthodox.
And you know what most people do,
you know the average,
you know,
pop star,
It might be about,
you know,
six people involved just to get the
album together.
You know,
somebody gets songwriter.
If somebody to get the producers in the
room,
you know,
um,
and then there could be chemistry's off,
you know,
this person might not mess with this
writer and this producer might not mess
with this artist and there's all this
going on and I'm pretty sure it gets
messy,
but that's this.
I've just been blessed not to deal with
that.
You know,
I have a,
I had an idea of,
you know,
what I wanted my career to be and I've
been sticking to that goal,
that,
that plan.
What was the idea if you could give us
like a one line of it?
Man,
I really just truthfully wanted to tell
my story and hopefully it inspired
others to not feel alone,
you know,
and understand that they can persevere
through anything,
you know.
And at that time of writing,
I like to tell people I don't even know
if I believed half of this shit.
I wrote,
you know,
like when I,
when I may pursue the happiness,
I was hopeful for happiness,
but I was in such a dark place at that
song.
For me it was more of a nightmare.
More than,
you know,
supposed to be a happy,
uplifting song.
You in a dark place.
How so?
Well,
just like I think coming to terms with
just the fame factor,
you know,
I always,
I always felt like I would get some type
of recognition,
you know,
I didn't know to what magnitude and you
know,
people say like,
oh,
you know,
what you signed up for,
but like really don't,
you know?
And you kind of have an idea and you
feel like,
oh that'd be cool.
But like I didn't and I still to this
day I don't look in the mirror and see
myself how other people see me,
you know.
So I never,
I never could prepare myself for,
for what came and everything came so
fast,
you know,
I had so that,
that brought on darkness.
Yeah.
Because I just,
I wasn't comfortable and then I had to,
you know,
I was in a place where all this
pressure,
all of a sudden a to be something and to
deliver a certain type of quality and
these are things that I've stepped up to
the plate and I was excited about doing,
but I didn't know that it would stress
me out to that magnitude that it did,
you know?
Uh,
I just didn't know that many people will
be watching and paying attention or care
that much,
you
know,
what was the number one consequence?
I just think the end that I didn't see
it being too too big of a consequence
that I couldn't deal with losing a lot
of my freedom.
But then I have a daughter,
you know,
I just worry so more about her now and I
just want her to have a normal life and
I want her to,
you know,
have that opportunity and not,
not I think about it more now than I did
then,
you know,
right before she was born.
Yeah.
I'm sure.
I have children.
Once you,
when you have children,
it really becomes more about them than
it doesn't even about you and a lot of
ways the way you live your life is now
always going to be like,
what's the best way for them,
and if it's not that way,
you're goIng to feel sick,
right?
You're going to feel like you're doing
something wrong.
Exactly.
It's a weird situation.
When you bring people into this world,
you're responsible for little tiny
people and you gotta you gotta teach
them shit and raise them and.
Oh yeah,
no one.
It's really hard.
I mean,
no,
I wouldn't say no one because I think
people are capable of intellectualizing
it,
but most people have no idea.
I just put it that way.
How intense the love a person has for
their kid is.
Yeah.
It's pretty intense.
I mean it's,
it's something that,
you know,
you have to have.
You have to have a child to experience,
you know,
you can't explain it.
You know,
it's,
it's just.
I mean,
my is man,
she everything.
It's also by like when you see kids that
are abused,
it's so extra disturbing.
yeah.
Because it's almost unimaginable who
would do that?
Who would do that to anyone's kid and
who would do that to their own kid?
It's just,
you know,
I've met people that have their parents
beat them and it's a fucking weird place
to be,
to talk to someone who is the person
they love more than anything.
beats the shit out of them when they do
something wrong,
you know?
And there's a difference between a
weapon and beating.
Well,
this adrian,
this nfl thing,
the guy who beat his kid with a stick,
you know,
the excuses that I guess like when he
was young,
that's how they treated him.
That's how he was raised.
Like,
I don't know what the kid did.
That was so horrible.
How old was this kid?
You know,
I man,
I don't even be reading into that really
young,
right?
Like nine or something like that.
Well,
whatever it was,
when you know,
when they talk about,
they say,
well this is the way he grew up,
which is true.
But man,
there's gotta be a way to end that
cycle.
You can't be beaten in kids with sticks
in 2014 and everybody should know that
by now.
I just think it's a cop out for people
to use that as an excuse.
We like those hall was raised even like
just with anything,
you know,
because that's just a cop out.
That's just somebody not wanting to
change and grow with the times.
I mean,
if we could find any way to be less
violent,
we should try it.
Yeah,
certainly.
Anything with these victims involved,
especially if the victim is a little
kid.
Yeah,
and by the way,
if you get kids used to the idea that
the person they love the most,
their parents is a person who's going to
beat them and hit them with things.
You are introducing violence into that
kid's life at a very early age and that
violence becomes a natural part of the
world,
becomes something they expect.
That's why they say that people who are
around their parents beating each other
up are more likely to be involved in the
abusive relationships.
When they get older,
they say that kids,
people who are hit by their parents or
people watched their parents hate each
other and were hit by their parents even
worse apparently.
It's awful.
Yeah.
I mean,
who's to say?
my mom spanked us,
you know,
but she had three boys to deal with by
herself.
Majority of the time,
you know,
it's not like,
I,
I don't,
you know,
look at my mom is a villain and you
know,
but she didn't beat us.
I can't say like I've been beaten by my
mom did some,
some hoe ass shit,
you know,
my mom reprimanded me and I deserve it.
You know what,
you're doing some sucker shit as a kid,
you know,
especially before you do it,
and you know that there's a,
a consequence that comes with that.
But I've never experienced that.
You know what I'm pretty sure a lot of
people are talking about right now,
but just like thinking it's okay to beat
up on your kids,
but like my daughter's four and a half,
I haven't had to reprimand her in that
way and I never will.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
I do.
I think it's a different situation too
when you've got a single mom dealing
with young sons like shit can get really
unruly.
That's what I'm saying.
It's like holy.
But even.
But even with that it,
they weren't beatings so it's like a
difference.
That is a big difference and that's,
that's something that people don't like
to admit.
Right.
It's never good to beat your kids,
but if you're a young woman who's
raising young boys and they don't
respect you.
Shit,
I got a yard yardstick and my mom had a
yard stick,
which you hit on my ass,
but it never hurt.
She would smack and I'm like,
oh,
okay.
I deserve that rating.
Not like stripped down naked.
Now after you're out the shower,
catch you off guard,
you know,
take the yard sake.
It's aluminum,
get on fire until it's fucking hot.
I saw video of these fucking idiots.
One kid put an iron,
a hot iron,
a little lost a bet kid lost a bet.
So You put a hot iron on his back like
after mark left the iron mark life too.
IT's not going to most likely fucking
some brand college kids,
man,
kids and kids today that are trying to
make videos of all this shit too.
It's like half the thing that they're
making videos while they're doing this
stupid shit.
It's the motivation.
It's like let's show people how fucking
idiotic we could be.
Verbal scholar,
we're lucky.
More people aren't.
That seems like people are telling
themselves accidentally left and right
trying to make these fucking videos.
You see that video and I'm not sure if
it's 100 percent real or not,
but the girl boils water and in films
hurt take this huge thing of boiling
water and pouring it over a dude's head
and he's like,
there's pictures of him just.
He's been in the hospital with all these
burns all over his body from yet
just from the als ice bucket of boiling
wAter.
Yeah,
totally serious.
I'll find it for you.
Oh my god.
People are so stupid
that it's probably real.
I don't know if it's real,
but I bet it's probably real.
People are dumb as shit,
man.
Fuck man.
That saddens me.
Fuck,
that's not cool.
Yeah.
You can overhear some conversations that
will make you lose your faith in
humanity if you imagine if you were
there in their goofy ass back yard,
but thinking about throwing boiling
water on this kid,
you'd be like,
you know,
dad is gonna.
Fuck You up for the rest of your life.
You're going to be covered in scars,
but that might as well be lava.
You idiot.
That's again,
like your life has changed forever after
that.
Yeah,
I mean it's a very least is going to be
some pretty significant scarring,
right?
Boiled in water,
the medical bills for that,
you know,
just the pain suffering just for one
stupid ass video where people can think
you're an idiot
tissue on your face for the rest of your
life because of.
Oh,
so were these kids uh,
like where they reprimanded and.
yeah,
it didn't really get into that part.
It just showed the video of the girl
doing it,
boiling the water and I'm doing it on
them and then make a news.
No,
I think it made the news because there
was a,
there was a photo of him later where
he's just sitting there all burnt,
like bandaged up.
His whole body's off
fucked up.
Fuck man.
What is this desire to make these
fucking goofy videos?
It's horrible in bullying now.
Has taken it to the next level because
kids are all filming them.
Bullying people and then putting it
online.
So now it doesn't mean bowling.
Bowling,
bullying,
price,
bullying.
I'm like,
they're going bowling.
They're going to go away.
I thought that was like a new thing
where you like to roll in a fetal
position.
Pins.
I was really trying to figure out what
you were saying,
but yeah,
but people are taking videos of them
beating up other kids and then putting
it online and sharing it around the
class and stuff.
So now you just see these videos of
these poor kids.
Well,
how are these kids not getting in
trouble?
I mean can't they are now,
but
the acts are already being done.
Yeah,
we live in a weird times.
Weird times took where we were talking
about earlier about people worrying
about your google glasses,
recording them because they're recording
everything and kids are growing up with
that.
It's like a part of a normal part of
life,
you know?
When you,
when you first got into the internet,
would you say you were in your late high
school days when you really started
getting into it?
Because that was,
I mean you're 30 now.
No computer except at the schoolhouse.
So that was the only time and then you
couldn't really explore that much.
You know,
it wasn't much out there because.
Well there was stuff out there but I
mean the teachers kept it restricted.
You know,
there were some sites you can go to and
you know,
you couldn't,
you couldn't watch porn and stuff back
then.
It's a big bummer.
Do that.
They can block stuff now in schools.
Right?
Do they block stuff?
They have to man.
I mean the internet is just so much more
on there now than there was back then.
But do they allow like porn sites,
like in dorms,
can kids get download porn?
Well,
I mean there's,
I mean jamie,
suddenly you have to go to a site no
more.
Well,
Yeah,
I mean you don't,
but you could always just download it
right from like a torrent.
Well you can just google porn and it'll
be right there.
Right?
That's true.
Yeah.
But I just wonder like bundles,
tips,
guys.
What's your favorite camera?
Do I Look in the one behind?
You know,
it's right.
There.
It is,
right?
You're a natural pitchman for the
internet.
The internet's official spokesperson
man.
They need to hit me up.
Let's go.
So,
you know,
getting out of high school and then
growing up like essentially like young
teens,
twenties,
all that like being able to like get
online at school and then being
completely immersed,
like being a part of like interactive
communities,
talking to people.
That's one of the first generations of
musicians that's able to do that.
It's able to go directly from high
school into communicating online with
people releasing stuff online and then,
you know,
becoming a part of this first generation
means a bunch now there's like a lot of
artists that are becoming really well
known because of just interacting with
people online.
Not even,
not even any music,
just being online and you know,
whatever happened in an identity on,
on,
on the internet,
you know?
Yeah.
There's that too.
Right?
That's something that people value about
you as well.
It's not just that,
you know,
they like music,
they like you,
they like to talk to you.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you've got a cool personality.
Like you're a cool guy,
you're a cool guy on social media,
you know you're yourself.
Yeah.
No,
I think that's important though.
I think it is my job and my calling to
also show the world a different type of
person in the position that I'm in,
you know,
someone,
it doesn't,
it isn't really big into conforming
because of my job because you know,
the people around me because of the
people I work with,
you know,
I always tell people I'm a human being
first before anything,
you know,
you're born naked,
you go in a really nice suit,
you know,
and,
and everything that happens in between,
it's just madness.
And we figured it out along the way.
But you know,
it's really interesting how a lot of
people just kind of like,
you know,
get this,
this blessing,
this job,
getting this business and they just get
really caught up and I never want to.
I never wanted to be that guy.
And the beauty of twitter,
it's like first I was really against it
because it's just so much,
you know,
unfiltered anus.
And I've learned to appreciate it.
Like literally I get a of competence
just by looking at my feet and seeing
maybe a couple of tweets that are like,
yo man,
keep doing it and I'm not necessarily
doing anything right now.
I doN't have any music coming out but
it's just a random tuesday and there's
some kid in Minnesota that's like,
yo,
I fucking love you dude.
Keep going.
we're listening and I might have needed
to hear that that day,
you know?
so like those kids don't know that that
means that much to me in the.
And it does.
So like I wasn't really that big.
We're talking,
you know,
and having such a presence online
because I was weird about it or not.
I got a grip over it.
It's no problem for me.
I love that I can,
you know,
just hit up a kid randomly and just make
their whole year,
you know,
just some competence in something that's
using it for good,
you know,
rather than me posting a picture of some
jewelry or some new thousand dollar
sneakers I bought it doesn't do anybody
any good other than being like,
damn,
I ain't got shit.
You know,
and that's the reality that people
realized and then it's like,
well,
I need to do what I gotta do so I can
have what he had and I don't want people
to think like that,
you know,
like when I post I like the posts,
like,
you know,
maybe my lactaid milk or does this come
from like lessons that you've learned
watching other people and,
but like the,
their behavior and you felt like the
shortcomings of their behavior once they
became famous.
Oh yeah man,
I'm watching everybody around me,
you know,
and I think and I,
and I and I kind of use,
I want kids to look at me and understand
what not to do.
You know,
when I was dealing with my drug issues
back in 2010,
2009,
you know,
I was heavy into cocaine and it was like
a big thing for me to go and it was like
a really big thing for me and it was
something that kept me level.
It's something that I felt like I needed
self-medicating.
And uh,
you know,
you felt like cocaine.
Keppra level.
Yeah man,
because I had this whole technique,
I don't know if I even should get into
this.
I don't even want to talk about this and
you don't have to go run around and talk
to do it.
You know what?
Let's just say I got into like,
you know what I would call like a
trifecta,
which was,
you know,
I will wake up in the morning,
I would know,
do coke immediately,
even before I had cereal,
breakfast and then I would have a beer
and then I would smoke weed.
So like I never wanted people to know I
was doing cocaine,
so the beer and the marijuana leveled me
out in a way where I was able to walk in
the streets and talk and,
and seem as though I was not anything
but deep inside I'm just like z with my
face and just like,
yeah,
that's right.
You know,
but what it did for me,
it completely numb to me.
I didn't care about anything and I was a
robot,
but also with it being so numb,
it allowed me to go out and meet my fans
and beyond the street.
So when a twisted way it did,
it did a positive thing for me and
that's why I didn't see it as an issue
and I was like damn,
today I went walking in soho with no
place to go and I was just high fiving
fans and shit.
Like it was just the most amazing
experience,
something that I never get a chance to
feel because I'm just like such a
recluse and I'm just at that time was
just weirded out when people recognize
me and just didn't want to go anywhere,
you know?
Yeah.
That's an issue with suBstances that can
help you in some ways,
but they're ultimately detrimental to
your health or wellbeing or your ability
to keep it together.
Yeah,
I mean I abused it,
you know,
it's not like the guy who like goes out
with his buddies and spring break and it
says like,
yeah,
let's do a pump.
And it said,
hey,
cooL.
You know,
those guys aren't real people in movies.
Everybody else is just too broke to go.
They just don't have the amount of money
that it requires to be a fucking
fulltime head.
It was definitely expensive,
man.
It was definitely expensive.
But you know,
I um,
you find like why you're doing it every
day.
Like was there a thing that made you
stop?
Because that's usually there's,
you got caught and then people started
to know I did it.
Yeah.
And it was like,
damn,
now everybody knows I do it.
It's not cool anymore.
Like it's only cool when no one knows is
a weird one,
right?
Yeah.
It's like I didn't really let you know,
I didn't let the public made me feel bad
about it though.
It was just kinda like,
fuck yes,
I can't do that no more.
But then also my daughter was born so it
was like,
you know,
it was,
it was like to kind of life lessons back
to back that I experienced in 2010 and
you know,
my daughter's birth and being arrested
were those two things because I think I
had already started toning down on my
cocaine use the beginning of that year.
But then I was the king of like
something tragic happened at or
something I felt was tragical stressful
and then spiraling back into it.
Just needing any excuse to be all right,
I'm going to go do cocaine now because
I'm set and I'm dealing with something
and I don't know how to deal.
Just like my way of copping out and
avoiding my issues.
Wow.
You know.
So it was like a block.
It was like maybe a couple months ago by
I'd be in Hawaii,
you know,
working on some stuff with kanye and I
never did cocaine or anything around
those guys.
I was like my time to detox when I will
be away because you're not if you do
coke,
coke with other people or alone.
And I felt weird about traveling the
world and every place I was at asking
people where the drugs was at.
So like it was something that I did,
you know,
at home,
at a certain time,
you know,
and which was,
I was able to kind of keep it together
and go out and work on my music and be
into it.
I had a system,
it was a weird six system I developed
for myself,
you know,
we're,
I was able to be cool if I wasn't in New
York,
but then when I was back in New York it
was on,
you know,
because it was just like being at home
in the apartment alone for hours on end.
Just really just got me,
you know,
and doing it just kinda like,
oh man,
I could just put on leaky lee and just
chill out for hours by myself.
And it's all good.
It's interesting that the arrest made
you want to stop because you really was
it because like the feeling like,
oh shit,
have an event has taken place.
Like this is obviously a big sign that
I'm going down the wrong direction.
I'm in,
I'm dealing with the legal system now
we're getting arrested and I was.
It was just more like,
did.
This is not scott [inaudible].
How in the hell did I let this become
scott mess?
HoW in the fuck do I got people looking
at me like I'm not scott mescaline and I
know what it was and I know how to fix
that.
And I went and I just,
It was just,
I didn't like how people were looking at
me at that moment in time.
So they're looking at you like you're a
coke fiend.
Yeah.
Crazy cracked out dude.
Like everywhere I would go it was just
these looks and I was just like,
man,
I just did a little blow
y'all motherfuckers acting like y'all
ain't never did a bump get outta here
man.
Like it was.
So I was like,
are you kidding me?
People love to be sanctimonious.
Yeah.
But,
but that's the thing.
When it happened,
I wasn't like,
you know,
on,
the next complex interview I did,
like I have a statement that I use this
camera.
I'm really sOrry to all my fans for you
guys knowing how I do cocaine now,
where I used to,
I don't do it anymore.
Uh,
I'm sorry if I let anyone down.
Fuck that.
It was really just like I'm dealing with
some shit if you don't understand it.
I don't give a fuck.
This is how I was surviving.
If I didn't do it,
I would have blew my brains out.
Well,
I like how you describe it to because
you're very honest about the positive
aspects of the effects and I think
that's super important.
And this was my contract by the way.
This release.
Sorry.
Don't worry about it.
everything's a proper method.
You're very muffled.
You're very honest about the positive
benefits of it.
Like people have this idea like you
shouldn't talk about positive benefits
of any drugs,
whether it's harmless drugs like
marijuana or dangerous drugs like
cocaine.
He maybe even especially dangerous drugs
like cocaine because the reality of what
you're saying,
your experience and the positive aspects
of your experience,
it's like he's promoting drugs when
clearly you're doing just the opposite.
You're talking about how you needed them
and use them and they helped you,
but the reality is it was because you
were dealing with an issue and it just
helps mask the issue,
but it did help him to lie and deny that
it clouds the issue for people dealing
with their own drug issues,
dealing with their current drug issues
or their past drug issues.
People aren't honest about it,
man.
It puts people in this weird place where
you don't mind.
If I wasn't for fucking meth,
I would have never started this
business.
The reason why I'm doing so well is
because I got on like,
I mean,
there's some people that can say that.
Probably the only reason why I could sit
here and say that is because like,
I've been four years clean man.
I'm not like running and I can speak
about it candidly and it's not something
I'm weird about.
And uh,
I've just grown so much since then.
And I also know that the more I talk
about it,
you know,
the more it'll help somebody else who be
dealing with it.
You know what I mean?
Definitely.
You know,
when you're in that,
it's probably just,
it seems like you can't get out of it
because it is like a thing,
you know what I mean,
and cycle and you get caught up in it.
And um,
you know,
I just know is with kids listening to me
talk now,
it's,
it could be helping a lot of people.
I'm not like one of those people now
that used to do cocaine and I'm like,
oh,
you're bad if you do cocaine or cocaine.
Spanish didn't do cocaine mean I don't
promote any drug but I'm not judging
anybody if they do it,
but know it's not like a big deal.
Like I did it and I just abused it in a
way and it didn't benefit me.
It didn't benefit scott.
I didn't like the person I was becoming.
There's some people that could do this
shit and they can live and do it in
moderation and it doesn't affect their
lives.
Like how it affected mine.
More power to them.
They got super powers if you asked me,
but I just have that,
you know,
it's a history of drugs in my family.
It was like my blood was waiting,
I was like,
yeah,
like,
let's go and I know that about myself
and I just had to make that choice.
I had to make a choice and I think
that's with anything,
cigarettes and you know,
four months,
five months done with now,
um,
you know,
you just have to make a choice.
And I made that choice for myself,
for my own health,
my daughter for a future,
for my fans,
you know?
Yeah.
A bunch of people quit cigarettes.
[inaudible] the anthony bourdain quit
cigarettes because his daughter to just
realize like,
what am I doing?
Yeah.
I mean,
for me,
Like my,
my,
my father passed away from cancer.
All my uncles passed away from cancer
and my father died when I was 11,
you know.
So that was an experience for me,
uh,
that kinda like traumatized me in such a
way.
But I can't,
you know,
when I got older I started to,
do everything that my father was into.
Like my dad smoked newports.
I started smoking newports 17,
you know,
my dad's,
he,
he loved mgd.
Miller genuine draft.
I fucking drank mgd millage and draft,
you know,
it was a tribute to him.
No,
I just kinda was becoming my dad in a
weird way.
And,
and you know,
it wasn't,
you know,
it was like one of those things you
don't.
I don't know,
I just kinda,
I never really had a relationship with
him,
so the only memories I have was just
this guy,
like,
you know,
like this guy was just so cool.
He had a cigarette and he had his beard
and he was always awesome and he was
there for me as a man and up until you
left,
you know,
uh,
and I think I kind of got caught up in
that and that's something that like,
you know,
I can't say the image of my father
drinking and smoking is what made me
drink and smoke,
but I can't say it didn't.
Right.
Do you think you took like comfort in
it?
Maybe like,
I think maybe,
yeah,
for sure.
I think everybody takes comfort and
smoking cigarettes.
It's like one of those things.
Yeah.
That's the grand trick that cigarettes
pull on you.
Did they give you comfort in that need
to replenish?
Like you give you a little stimulant
from the nicotine and all the chemicals
that are in the cigarette and then
you're so addicted to it that you have
this weird when you don't have it and
then when you smoke it relieves that
stress and you think that it's actually
calming you down.
But all it's doing is feeding the
dragon.
It's like a drug.
it's anything.
Oh,
it's a drug.
Nicotine is one of the craziest drugs
all time because there's legalist book
and you could just get it anywhere.
Like they presented in such a way where
it's all cool but you know,
and,
and that's another thing too.
I don't come to my aunties.
Smokers either like friends come of my
house,
they smoke,
I don't shush them outside.
And you know like you can smoke in the
house.
It's not that really.
You don't mind people stinking up your
house.
There's on cigarettes bother me.
I smoked for a long time and you know,
it's not like I got people chain smoking
in the house.
Somebody needs a cigarette,
one or two school.
I have friends that used to smoke and if
they smell it,
they get sick and I'm cool with.
I'm cool with it.
I just,
it's more just like for people that
can't stand,
that there's people that might still
have an issue with the addiction,
but if I smell it or anything like that,
it's kind of just saying,
oh,
it's not for me.
It doesn't really bother me.
You don't have a poll that doesn't pull
you towards it.
You don't want to smoke it again.
I mean I get,
I can't say like occasionally,
and this is something that just will
forever happened because I was addicted
to the shit,
but like I can't say like after a meal,
a really good meal,
I'm like,
oh man,
a cigarette would be nice,
but I don't do that no more.
So that's that.
And then I said,
wow,
good for you.
You know what I mean?
But I got hypnotized.
So hypnotists.
Yeah.
And do you remember them advertising
you?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I remember because you have to,
you have to receive the information,
you know,
that he's telling you,
you have to really process what he's
saying because it's really a reeducation
of the dangers of,
you know,
it's kinda like what we learned in
health class when we were in school as
kids,
you know,
it's no different except,
over time the fear is not,
you know,
as heightened as it was when we were
fourth graders sitting in the room.
But our teachers saying like,
oh it does,
your lungs are nice and pink like this.
Oh,
and if you smoke they're black like
this.
It's not over time we see pop culture,
we see the james deans,
we see everything going on and then it
doesn't seem as dangerous.
And,
and basically this guy reminds you of
the dangerous and kind of reboot you.
And it's like psycho shit.
It is kind of.
And as an adult you take it a little
bit.
It's really funny just how the cycle of
life goes.
It's like,
at my age,
I guess I was able to look at it in the
same way I saw it as a fourth grader,
you know,
and just kind of realized,
oh,
this is,
this is hurting me.
Talked me through it.
They lie down on the couch and close
your eyes.
They turn the lights down.
Well,
I had him come to my crib,
you know,
because I'm wanting to feel comfortable
and I had a knife there.
So if you tried any funny moments,
but I'm just going to let you know,
touching me,
I didn't know what was happening.
I had,
I had to shake my pillow in case there's
a comedian that,
a comedy store,
no bullshit.
There was a comedian and used to go to
the comedy that used to hypnotize
women is.
His thing was that he was a comedian,
but he also did some hypnotist work and
like he would always hypnotized girls.
And like I remember very clearly one
time I was walking to the back of the
comedy store and he was talking to a
girl and she just pulled her head away
and she goes,
no,
I don't want you to hypnotize me.
And I was like,
wow,
it's true.
That is out there hypnotizing people.
That's fucked up man.
So cool.
When they do do it in your bed?
No,
we were in the living room on the couch
and you kinda just sits there and he
don't sleep on your back.
Okay.
So you fully stretched out pillow behind
her head.
Just relaxing.
And then when they count you down,
what does it feel like?
It feel like you're tired as hell.
Like slipping into like,
you know,
a dream system really relaxed.
You just really relaxed.
It's like.
Had you been touch before this?
No.
First time.
Only time.
Only wants us at three times.
Three times three and three separate
sessions.
Does their weeks apart,
does it feel different each time you do
it?
Or does it feel the same?
No,
after the first time it's like he does
his thing.
It's like after the first one it's like
you don't,
um,
uh,
you can smoke between.
So it's like we did ours from tuesday to
tuesday,
so they came that tuesday,
that whole week I was allowed to smoke
right after the first session,
after the first therapy session and the
hipaa hypnosis.
Then after that second week you're done
completely.
Then after that third week it's like
kinda like reestablishing that.
It's done and that's the final one.
But after that first one,
it's like the final week.
Right.
So to come out of that hypnosis instill,
you know,
him telling me like I can still smoke.
I still had this urge to like,
I don't know if I want to do that,
you know,
like I was allowed to smoke.
He said it was cool.
I remember like my first cigarette after
like the hypnosis,
I waited like a couple of hours,
like I had the,
I had the,
that urge but I wasn't so quick to jump
into it.
Why did he say he could smoke?
What's the logic behind it?
You ask him?
Just kinda like took to,
I don't know,
to give it a minute to give you that
last week too,
just know that this going to be up after
because he tells you like,
all right,
so just this last week you could smoke
and then after that second session
you're done.
So when you're going under and he's,
he's telling you I'm going to count you
down and then boom,
you're under.
Do you remember the first things he said
to you?
Like do you,
were you conscious of it?
Yeah,
yeah.
He's just basically,
you know,
just talking about,
the dangers of cancer and what it could
do to you and how it's just nasty and
it's Poison and just everything you
could imagine that we'll kind of put it
in a way for a human being.
Understand and get it like,
okay,
this is dangerous because that's what it
is.
I think the average person that smokes a
doesn't see the danger in it like that
because you might see,
you know,
the,
the old lady that's 80,
90 years old that's been smoking on her
days,
it looks like she's fine,
you know.
And he'd just be like,
well,
I'll probably be that lady or I'll
probably be that guy or you know,
but the reality is you don't know,
you know,
and it's like a gamble every time.
and it's like literally I'm him just
kinda,
he'll give me scenarios too.
And I don't even know how much I could
reallY talk about because he,
he sells this,
this is like a thing,
you know,
you just really gives you examples,
just like scenarios,
like simple example,
like if you knew someone was uh,
you know,
if you were dating a girl and you knew
that,
you know,
she was known for poisoning her
boyfriend's putting poison,
uh,
rat poison in her food,
but there wasn't real approved.
But every guy she did it kind of got
murdered.
But hey,
you know,
we're dAting her for awhile.
And she said no,
she wanted to finally cook for,
you know,
like,
what would you do,
you know what I mean?
Like would you,
if you knew for a fact that she was a
killer,
would you let her cook your food?
Would you let this person into your
house?
No,
you would say I'm not fucking with the
chicken.
I mean guys stopped messing with a chick
if she calls too many times,
like you know,
like it's just kind of the reality of
like,
man.
Well anytime you've seen any obsessive
behavior,
anything dangerous people,
but it's kind of just that reality,
like it's poison.
It's going out your way to buy poisoned
to put in your system.
So you felt much more in touch with the
reality of what it is.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
I just,
I've seen there's been curious about
like what the state is like of being
hypnotized.
You don't feel,
you don't feel disconnected?
No,
I felt like I was,
I could have woke up at any minute.
I felt like if somebody or if you try
something,
I could have smacked the shit.
Ain'T really worried about him trying to
y'all because just like you just like,
you know what I'm saying,
if you've never done it hypnosis and you
see in the movies,
it just seemed like you kinda like
vulnerable and,
and,
you know,
I just,
I didn't know what extent that would
feel like,
you know,
I didn't want to be like,
I know what you're saying.
You know what I mean?
So did he ever.
Have you ever seen like one of those
comedy hypnotist shows?
No.
You should go and check bark like a dog
or whatever.
Yeah.
It's just one guy that does it
particularly.
Right?
It's,
he's known for it.
Well,
there's a bunch of people all over the
country to do it.
Oh,
okay.
This is like a thing.
Yeah.
It's a thing,
man.
I've seen her.
When I was starting out in boston,
there was this comedy club called
stitches and uh,
they had a guy named Frank Santos.
She did it there all the time and I
thought it was bullshit at first and
then from being there all the time,
I got to see all these shows.
I realized like,
whoa,
no,
you can just hypnotize some people.
Oh yeah.
And you get some dudes to come in their
own pants.
They would think they were having sex,
they would take care of sex on stage and
they will be on the ground like humping.
And he would tell them when they were
gonna come and they would come and
they'd be embarrassed and then they'd go
and sit down.
Yeah,
I'd be embarrassed.
It's like somebody with a ghost hand
coming.
They're jerking you off when you're not
noticing it.
It was so cool.
Some people apparently are super
susceptible to it,
but he knew he knew when people were
under and when they weren't under.
That's why I was.
I'm always confused.
Like you.
So you,
you were coNscious but you were under.
Yeah,
like he'll do things like um,
once you say yes,
you know,
so he'll,
he'll know to check and make sure that
you're under or whatever.
There's certaIn things that he'll,
he'll do like and I'm paying for it.
So it's not like,
you know,
I'm my lying right now.
It is under though.
That's what's confusing to me.
What is that state,
I guess between dreaming and awake?
I mean I'm definitely like the
understate is more just like a relaxed
feeling.
Not like sleep,
right?
But it can be.
It can be,
you know,
you could feel I could sleep because
you're breathing slower and that's what
sleep is like,
you know,
you're relaxed.
And to us that's what sleep feels like.
Not that relaxed state,
but your conscious conscious.
I hear him crystal clear.
I'm not in deep sleep,
you know,
it feels like it,
but I'm,
I'm not.
I'm hearing everything clearly.
I'm understanding him.
You know,
a saw.
I'm not snoring here.
It's not like it's not weird you feel
president,
but then you just are really,
really chill.
So it's just basically like some weird
middle state.
yeah.
It's the in between of some shit that
happens that motherfuckers know how to
do.
like I've never experienced anything
like it.
What's the difference between one
session one and session two,
session three m,
I can't be the difference between
session one and session two.
I can say I can't really differentiate
between session two and tHree.
Are you allowed to smoke out?
You're allowed to smoke after one or
you'll have a smoke after two,
after two,
you're done after two.
You don't want to really.
I think that's when he actually like,
I think too,
the difference between the first stage
and second stage,
the first stage,
she doesn't really instill anything.
Like when you wake up from this you're
not going to be smoking cigarettes
anymore.
Like he doesn't say anything like that.
He's just educate you.
And then it's like,
no,
you're going to come back,
you know,
and I'm gonna call you out from from 10
all the way up to one,
you know,
and count you up and cut you up.
But he doesn't say,
he says like,
you can smoke this week,
you know,
and,
but after this you're going to be done.
You know?
so like you come out of that first state
just kinda like,
okay.
But like I said,
I was hesitant to smoke.
I really wanted to smoke.
But would it be something that,
that was something that stuck still in
that first session that made me like,
oh man,
is it is kind of gross,
you know,
success rate.
Did he say iT literally?
I mean,
he says everybody does it,
but I know,
you know,
I'm pretty sure a lot of people have a
hard time with it,
you know,
it's not,
it's just you really in,
this is what he says and anybody that I
know that it's done it too.
It's really just kind of like,
you have to be ready,
you know,
in a weird way.
You just got to be ready.
And I think that's with anything in
life.
I mean they tried to make it like this
thing,
like you've just got to be ready,
but like anything,
marriage,
you know,
even just dating someone or whether it's
a job,
you just got to make that choice and
just really want it for yourself to
really commit,
you know,
in and out.
Really it costs money to like you spend,
you're paying this money.
I mean,
it's like a waste of time,
you know,
otherwise,
and he's the type of person where even
though he's getting paid,
he's,
he cares to do this passionate.
He devoted his whole life to this.
This guy,
um,
carrie gainer.
Uhm,
I'm gonna give you his contact so you
can,
he has a twitter page and stuff and he
does this whole thing where it was going
to get bombed with dick pics right now.
Coming in hot,
coming in hot bro.
Just,
let's just say his name.
It worked on my sister.
give his twitter page out.
They'll get,
they'll get them hypnosis.
Like my,
my sister got hypnotized and it worked
for,
for about a year.
And then she said one day she just woke
up and it was gone and she just started
smoking.
Carrie gainer?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's um,
what,
what is this twitter.
You want to give it out?
Oh yeah,
sure if you want.
Yeah.
So find it,
cause he's,
he's a dope dude man.
He's the nicest guy.
He totally.
As soon as I saw him,
I,
I knew I wasn't going to have to shank
them,
but you never know.
You never know joe rogan.
I mean not everybody has the data that
you have dude,
where people just like not going to try
it.
They'll still try a session.
One involve chlorophyll.
Tough for the squeeze.
The sweeter the juice is twitter is
carrie gainer a k e r r y g a y n o r
carries one of those weird words that
dudes are still allowed to have,
you know,
but it's a weird one.
He has a twitter for,
for his,
his name,
for his business name and a dude,
k e r r y.
I mean,
it is,
you can get away with it,
but it's strange.
I think it's an irish thing though too.
Is it?
Okay.
It could be that or it could be a
dominant wife.
Wishes she had a girl.
Well,
I promised a promise you that it is not
what's going on.
He had a girlfriend in high school and
uh,
her,
her mom had a boys name because the dad
wanted a boy.
So he named her a boy's name.
It was the craziest situation.
I've known people that have had that.
Yeah,
for sure.
Those ugly though,
because,
you know,
she didn't get along with her parents,
like her mom did not get along with her
parents.
And uh,
she always resented that her dad gave
her a boy's name.
That's creepy.
But you can just change it.
Yeah.
But it was,
it was like a love Missing thing.
What was the name wasn't I want to say,
come on.
I don't want to say let's make it mike,
but that's not as fast because girls,
I didn't want to go named michael.
Now it's,
it's my girlfriend,
my girlfriend from high school,
his mom.
So I don't think,
you know,
understood.
Understood.
But uh,
she's a nice lady.
But you could tell she wasn't really
into people.
Especially men.
Yeah.
So it's the same name.
Men with the same name.
She had this strange boyfriend for
awhile.
It's very weird wHen you see like how
other people grow up and you see like,
oh,
that's where that comes from.
like you get some weird thing about men
and then you go,
okay,
let me see what's going on in your
house.
Oh,
let me see what's going on.
A mom has a boy's name and this is her
boyfriend and he's a mess.
Okay.
Yeah,
I see how it'd be weird about dudes.
It's science.
It's not your fault.
It's like do it science in your own
house.
That's fucked up,
man.
You know,
that's the one thing when it,
when everybody judges people and
everybody does love to judge people.
The reality is not everybody starts off
in the same spot.
You know,
some people get a shit spot in life,
you know?
and then some people I think a bad spot
or an an,
an imperfect spot a lot of times
motivates them.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
like that happened with you.
Oh,
most definitely.
Yeah.
And I think about it like I,
and that's what a lot of my,
my,
my issue came through you,
you know,
early on in my career I had this moment
where literally I had like security and
a car service everywhere I went and I
just started to feel like richie fucking
rich.
IT was just,
I was like,
I got to chaperone.
It's like my mom has this person with me
every where I go to make sure I don't
get in trouble and then like she feeds
my bank account as long as I'm good.
Like it just felt really weird,
you know?
And uh,
anyone coke he started to get on because
it was because,
you know,
I came from a natural thing,
you know what I'm saying?
It was kinda like,
it was hard for me to like the way of
life was just a different transition,
you know?
Yeah.
I would imagine that's got to be a,
that's a big leap to come from nothing
and then become a famous entertainers.
Wealthy is a very treacherous and
difficult path to,
to manage,
I would imagine.
I think most people's motivation is to,
you know,
and I can't say I didn't fall victim to
it was just kind of prove people wrong
in a way.
Oh yeah.
And that was a,
I mean,
it wasn't anger that fueled me though.
It was just more like,
okay,
I'll show you.
Well,
it's your own desire to determine
self-worth.
Right,
right.
So it didn't,
it wasn't misguided.
It was always just like,
okay,
I'm doubted the odds are against me,
but I know what I'm feeling and this is
what I want.
Pink.
Sign your hand and then you turn it into
a tattoo.
Pink floyd.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
I like to feel like a early on in my
career I was,
I was pink a bit,
you know,
putting up these walls and,
and I kind of connected with that story,
uh,
early on and,
and you know,
I was,
you know,
really into to floyd so much that it
inspired my sound.
A pink floyd and electric light
orchestra.
Really ultimately elo wow.
Determine the sound scapes for my entire
career with vinyl you to like listen to
it on old vial.
I,
um,
I don't collect vinyls.
I know buddies that do,
I have,
I haven't gotten into that,
you know,
I feel like that is a hobby that I
eventually want to get into.
I'm not experienced,
you know,
a lot of music that I,
would love to on vinyl because I just
haven't gotten into that.
It's supposed to have a different sound
quality to it.
Right.
Why release all my music on vinyl and,
and you know,
all my album covers are designed for
vinyl covers.
Like,
and that's a lot of things that a lot of
people don't know that.
but you know,
I designed on my album covers for vinyl
and,
and for that presentation to be able to
see the artwork and you know,
have this,
you know,
and be able to hear it in this certain
quality.
You know,
you can't play kid cuddy back in 1960.
At least.
You can kind of get a little taste of
you.
So w we um,
we mix for vinyl,
we do everything for vinyl.
ultimately,
you know,
we were not doing this shit for,
for,
you know,
itunes and mp3s,
you know.
Um,
yeah,
the ritual is just getting the vinyl and
then on their end.
Yeah,
it's a thing,
what,
that thing is rare today.
Like people don't sit down and listen to
music together.
Like I'll like if a friend is in a car,
I'll play him some shit.
like listening to this,
check this out or if we're here in the
studio,
maybe I'll hook,
I got this bluetooth speaker thing it,
hook it up to that.
But most of the time you doN't sit down
with dudes and just listen to music.
But I remember when I was a kid,
my stepfather,
his friends,
they would,
they would put on an album and they
would sit down and listen to an album.
Oh yeah.
You know,
they would experience.
You would get the new one or whatever
the hell it was.
THey,
I remember they had the new billy joel
album.
I was a little kid,
man.
That was the,
it was a,
the piano man.
I remember when it was new,
they pulled that shit out.
I was probably like seven or something
like that.
And uh,
they put it on the record player and
everyone just sat around and listened to
this billy joel album.
That's what people did back when there
was two tv channels.
And I have,
I kind of imagined that's what my fans
do and that's kinda like how I create
and a lot of people might not.
It's like,
that's why when I released a single,
for example,
it might be some weird shit that people
are just like,
what is this?
But in the context of the story,
when you consume the entire album,
that makes sense.
You know,
because I don't really make records for
singles,
you know,
I make.
I'm making an entire album here.
This is a project.
What percentage of your music is
listened to by products?
Something like 80.
I think more than that.
I think 100 percent talking about the
moon again,
right?
The fuck in,
right on,
in there,
man.
That's funny man.
But yeah,
I think that,
that,
that's what's missing it.
Mainstream music.
I think everything is always moment to
moment.
Single,
the single who's got who or what record
is not about like sitting down and
having an experience,
you know,
and I'm going to always create with that
in mind and I think as long as I do
that,
I always have an audience because
there's people like us that want that
experience,
that want that feeling,
uh,
to get the homies together.
AnD even if we've all heard the album a
trillion times,
just to put it on from the beginning and
let it play,
you know,
it's just dope,
man.
Nope,
nobody really does that anymore.
Everybody's kind of like spotify this
here at pandora and just skipping around
and skipping around,
skipping around,
and that's because music is designed
that way,
you know?
Um,
but you,
you step into like,
you know what we do,
the kids know.
It's like,
okay,
you by kid cudi album,
you probably have your friends come
over.
It's a thing.
It's like don't open it until I get
there.
It's a very big deal and I love that
there's that type of ritual going on
because like,
I do it too.
I go and I buy my own album when it
comes out and kids see me in best buy
arguing,
like why is it in the front,
but no,
I'm not doing this shit now.
I don't talk to anyone and it's not in
the front moving.
Hell yeah.
Legal.
No,
I think there's digital terrorism but,
but it's kind of like I look at it like
this,
if I'm not going out on a day,
I'm buying my album.
You can't expect other people to do it.
You know?
If I got to support my own self too,
and know that's hilarious.
You're supporting your own self.
That doesn't even work that way.
Just keep the money in your pocket and
steal your own album.
I really do believe where he really
truly support yourself.
Get caught shoplifting or album that so
everyone would go.
That's a big story on tmz.
That's like you would be a front page
guy.
I'd be a be a,
but you know,
like I really do believe that man.
It's just like if You're selling some
merge you,
you gotta promote your merchant kids.
Got to see you wearing your own stuff.
It's you got to let them know like,
hey,
I'm done with this shit too.
He's covered in his own murder,
never wears anything but death squad,
tee shirts and death squad have to make
my own closet business and make his own
crocs.
Croc is going to walk around and he's
going to become that guy.
I want to pair those Blue crocs with
white socks.
Kenny's on them.
Would you ever wear crocs outside?
It's so weird that you said that job
went to the magic castle last night.
I knew I had to buy new shoes because I
don't wear dress shoes.
I just remember up there.
Huh?
No,
I got invited.
A lucky bastard.
You really want to go to that just to
see what's up.
Just I,
I just drive by it every damn day.
I want to know what's going on.
That'd be easy.
Yeah,
I can get you gonna going.
Okay.
But I had to get dress shoes and I was
joking with my girlfriend that I was
just going to buy black croc so I could
use them other times than just dressing
up and she thought I warm the whole time
because I had an old pair of crocs and
like these are what I buy.
And she's like,
oh,
you know,
he knows.
And then right before I left I switched
on,
but we had this whole thing last night.
No,
crocs are great.
Do you own crux jump?
No,
no,
but I mean I don't have any problem with
wearing them.
I would wear them if there were that
comfortable,
but I heard they're good.
It's my walk outside and get the mail or
do something else.
Either skate shoes or wear converse.
All stars.
That's where I were.
Yeah.
That's good.
See,
I got these leather.
Chuck's on.
Nice.
they're comfortable.
I got these beeps Today.
Oh,
those are nice.
What are those?
They donate a couple of years,
maybe five years old.
This came up.
I liked it.
I liked the star on the side.
It's pretty dope.
Skate shoes are probably the most
comfortable like them and like chuck
taylors,
those are all pretty much.
I used to only wear vans and and then my
girl got me into wearing jordans and
stuff like that.
They're built.
That's.
I get it.
Now.
They are the most comfortable shoe in
the rural.
Welcome.
Welcome to the final.
You've got Jordan
on mtv cribs.
Were you going to your house?
You've got all these jordan's like
stacked up around your place.
Look at this right here.
Oh no.
You son of a bitch.
Those are giant laser from back to the
future.
Is that what their phone?
Is it a.
Those are the mags and nike max.
Are those comfortable?
yeah,
they are man.
It designed the shit out of those.
Yeah.
Joe,
have you ever wear a pair of jordans or
any of those kinds of shoes?
I haven't in a long time.
When I used to have a deal with nike,
I used to have one of those things where
like when I was on newsradio that'll
give you free shoes and on fear factor
too.
They just send me boxes of free nike's.
Wow.
But I just stopped.
I don't really do tv anymore.
It'd be rude if I kept calling them the
yellow so you know,
I still need that shit.
What are you going to do with this?
It's going to work out your shit.
but they had a thing where you could
call them and they would give you free
stuff.
Yeah.
But I,
so they would give me a bunch of stuff
that I wouldn't wear like white and red,
like basketball shoes and be like I can
wear these,
but a lot of like cross trainers and
shit,
they have comfortable shit but I got
into smaller sole things that have like
less.
You'll feel the ground more like chuck's
like chuck taylors.
I liked that better.
I can't perform in jordan's my discovery
recently.
Really?
In what way?
I just can't move.
I can't imagine that if you live on
stage combat boots,
I fuck with army boots with a cigar
hanging out of your mouth,
like fucking sergeant fury.
It was ridiculous.
How about timberland's?
Um,
I've seen people do it in all sorts of
sorts of footwear,
but for me,
I'm moving around a lot and it's hard
for me to move as quick and as nimble.
Why is That?
With jordans I'm going to feel that were
athletic shoes while I'm not like,
well first off I'm not like I don't have
them laced up.
Oh,
you know,
like I'm about to go play full court,
you know what I mean?
So there's that,
there's the.
So they're slIpping around just the
whole like,
you know,
trying to be fresh thing about it.
So they're not like really being worn
how it's supposed to be worn.
But then like,
there's nothing like converse where it
feels like you're literally dancing
barefoot,
like on your tippy toes from one end to
the stage to the other.
And that's literally,
I find like the best sneaker for me on
stage.
Yeah.
Converse with the best for working out
too.
Like if you lifting with stuff,
you just feel the ground with them.
There's very little padding but it makes
you think like just dudes like julius
erving and like back in the day where he
used to wear those and actually play
basketball games and um,
that's incredible.
That's what they wore.
Chuck taylors,
they would play a basketball game with
no protection basically,
you know,
ankles were getting broken.
Oh,
they probably snapped.
But then again they probably developed
tougher ankles,
you know,
like they grew up doing that.
Does that make any sense?
Yeah.
Jamie shakes his head.
He's a fucking physio,
vascular ankles,
man.
I'm there.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't make sense.
Like if You used it,
it would get stronger.
No,
like,
like if you put too much bracing around
it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would imagine there's a letter right
there.
You these two.
Joe's.
Hello kitty.
Long and I'm on am my own camera.
Okay,
I'll make sure he's on camera.
We don't want the world now.
He smokes weed.
So,
uh,
we,
we got in touch because you reached out
to me on twitter out of nowhere.
Oh yeah,
that was cool.
We was on twitter talking.
Shit,
I love what you do joe.
I'm a big fan.
I'm sorry you don't mind us now please.
Okay.
Hello everybody.
Hello.
This is what everybody wants to see,
right?
This is what you guys want to see.
They want to see you shoot heroin bumps
and the other one.
Brian is a bunch.
There's a bunch in that one.
Um,
Yeah.
Do some bumps.
Dog.
I'll Tell you what,
joe,
when I get married,
I'm going to invite you to my.
When me and you going to do some bumps?
No,
I've never done.
I've never done coke.
Well,
here's the thing.
I don't think I'm ever going to get
married.
So beautiful.
This works out for.
I remember saying that to get you to be
gotten joe.
I want to be gotten bro.
It's definitely better than not wanting
to be gotten,
been,
gotten is better than wanting to be at.
Man.
I'm joking.
By the way.
I just dicking around.
Everybody wants love.
It's the truth.
Oh for sure,
dude.
It's one of the weirdest things when you
know somebody who just can't ever
fucking get it right.
They can't find somebody to care about.
like everybody knows this one girl or
one dude that just can't get a
girlfriend or a boyfriend.
There's always like the struggle.
They're always saying gold.
They can't
find anybody worth a fuck.
That's sad.
Shit.
They can't find anyone to fuck.
Fuck,
fuck.
I mean almost everybody has lower your
standards enough to find somebody
that'll fuck.
Yeah.
That's,
you know,
I mean,
I,
I'm not saying that I meet,
I don't meet people that aren't worth a
fuck,
but it is hard to find somebody,
you know,
and,
and it's just,
it doesn't,
it's no different whether you're a
celebrity or not,
you know,
it's just hard to meet people and you
don't.
it's also,
it's hard to.
It's hard to really,
I guess trust and believe,
you know someone.
I mean,
how well do you ever really know someone
you know and,
and you know,
how long does it take to say that you
really know someone?
How do you know what somebody is giving
you is really then,
you know,
it's true.
I mean,
there's definitely people that were
bullshit you and there's definitely
people that have layers to their
personality that you didn't imagine.
You just can't,
especially if you cross them,
if you develop some sort of a feud with
them and you find out that they're
willing to just go completely psycho on
you and take shit to the next level and
start banging on your fucking door in
the middle of the night Screaming,
get that hoe out of there.
Know that's me.
I,
that's what you do.
That's your moving on.
Totally.
Girl can be that guy mentally insane in
the course of a relationship.
Um,
but no,
I feel you man.
It's,
it's.
But I,
I,
I like to keep a stance where it's like,
fuck that,
you know,
I don't,
I don't need anyone but deep down,
like everybody wants somebody that's
like a companion.
You know,
there's somebody that's a best friend
and a teammate and I,
I kind of,
you know,
will always want that,
but it's not something that I'm like
searching for,
like I used to,
like it was for awhile.
I was like,
I felt like that was the only way I can
get a certain happiness in my life,
you know,
just come to terms with it and you
realize that that's not the way.
And you know,
I'm just very hopeful,
you know,
that I'll run into somebody but it is
tough,
you know,
and I,
and I made a lot of cool chicks,
you know,
I meet a lot of cool tricks and you
know,
it's just for me,
it's just really,
it's tough about being at the right
place and right time when,
you know,
sometimes you're not in the right place
in your own head to be a good person to
be in a relationship with.
Yeah.
And that's,
and I really do.
I feel like,
you know,
at this time in my life,
there's a lot of soul searching that
scott needs to do.
Scott is talking about himself in the
third person.
THird person.
Yeah.
Scott,
because I didn't want to admit that,
you know,
so when I have to admit shit like that,
flaws and all,
I have to step out.
Scott needs to get his shit together.
I never.
He was like,
I have to get my shit together.
It sounds so much worse.
Uh,
jefferson starship man,
they said it back in the sixties.
Don't you want somebody to love?
Don't you need somebody to love?
Wouldn't you love somebody to love?
Yeah,
you better find somebody to love.
And I'm pitching Saying,
I really
feel like,
you know what I actually want to add
before I go into this,
how did you meet your lady?
Like was it just like everybody says
when you don't,
when you least expect it.
Like was it at.
I like to get you in my personal life on
podcast because I think people fixate on
other people's personal lives too much
and it gets weird when people start
talking to you in public about your
personal life and you don't even know
them.
Okay.
So I just found there's no benefit in
doing that,
but I just met her in a normal
environment.
I met her in a bar.
You can meet people.
It doesn't.
It's like,
where do you go?
Well,
if you go there,
like people say,
oh,
you never meet somebody in a bar or you
never meet somebody at a bowling alley.
Did you go to a bowling alley?
Yes.
Okay.
Well then you could meet somebody at a
bowling alley.
People very.
It's just finding them and that's
what's.
It's not that easy.
Finding the right combination of you and
them and you might be terrible to other
people.
Like other people might think like the
last thing I want is just crazy.
Scott motherfucker in my life right now
that it's of course,
sorry girls compatible with each other
and everybody wants to take that as a
sign of rejection or a sign as a sign
of,
you know,
your own lack of self worth or something
like that.
But it's not that somewhere out there
there's someone who enjoys your
personality.
If you,
if you're honest and you're nice,
like if you're honest with yourself,
you understand your flaws,
whatever you're trying to do in this
life,
try to do it well.
If you've got,
you know,
you got a lot of positive energy about
you,
you could probably find somebody.
You got to be worth finding.
Yeah,
I got to get out the house.
JoE got to get out the house.
That's step one.
Step two,
I play a lot of xbox,
so that's my thing.
And whenever you want to come over,
but you could either go deep or you
could get out of the house.
You could just go oculus rift and lived
your whole life.
That's like common man.
Yeah.
It's a neat character.
A date in this other realm.
this kind of like her,
like,
you know,
it's just my baby in this world.
She's hot as fuck.
And then when you're done banger,
you pull her mask off and it's,
you know,
is that.
Well,
the thing is you can always power down.
It's not something you got to deal with
all the time,
you know,
maybe maybe they get you like a
hypnotist just climb inside your head.
I want the world to know that I'm part
time a comedian when I,
when I want to.
so there's some,
a lot of sarcasm.
So just bear with us here.
Kinda like,
you know,
decipher most of it.
Yeah.
You don't want them to take it.
Any of your quotes in because they come
from.
I come from a world where anything that
come out of my mouth is taken.
So literally.
So it's like I want to make sure that we
understand we're dicking around here and
exactly.
You know.
And that's why I came here today because
I don't do interviews and I don't sit
down and talk to them because this
shit's weird.
You know,
people aren't cool now advIses coolest
joe rogan bro.
You know,
so like a big fan.
Like I said,
and I know you're talking about
psychedelics and I saw something you
were talking about one time when you
were talking about how you went into a
one.
Is it one of those chambers isolation
tank?
Yeah,
and I was in a video I think.
No,
I didn't.
It wasn't video on brian made a video
about it when I gave away my tank.
It was like one of your best videos.
You own one bra?
Yeah.
Well yeah,
I own one now,
but I had another one.
My old one.
I gave it away online.
So we had this thing get them.
Well you could buy them,
buy them online.
Shit.
Yeah.
I mean there's an order.
There's a bunch of different companies
but.
Well we'll talk afterwards because will
ask you where you live and then I'll get
to tell your best option,
but the place that you want to visit.
There's a place called the flOat lab and
it's in venice and the guy who runs it
is my friend crash.
He's actually been on the podcast before
and he's the master when it comes to
float tank technology.
He's the guy that really changed the
entire industry because they used to be
like kind of home models that were like
kind of flimsy and you know,
they would have all sorts of issues.
He fixed all the issues,
changed all the filtration system,
made a much more durable,
much bigger,
better insulation,
like he's turned them into these
incredible,
like complete next level devices.
That's,
that's in California,
so the best places in California.
If there's another place that's in
austin that is probably right up there
and that place.
Fuck,
I forget the name of it.
I got it on my instagram feed.
All this man.
I need all this information.
Do you live in California?
Okay,
well if you live in California then
there's one place to go.
That's the float lab.
Here's.
If you look at the video and here's
joe's isolation tank he had at his
house.
This is his old one,
the amazon indians,
and he brought it back to them.
I'm talking about the movie altered
states,
which is where I found out about
isolation tank.
It was like 11 or 12 years ago,
returns back into the box after double
filter.
On top of that,
I also have this right here,
which is a an oxygen scrubber just like
they have at those oxygen bars.
Well,
this,
this little machine right here,
pulls oxygen,
pure oxygen out of the air,
and it pumps it through this to where
this gets it all gets pumped into the
tank while I'm lying in it.
So I get pure oxygen,
oxygen,
which is amazing for your mind anyway.
It makes you feel very refreshed.
And then on top of that,
I'm in this weightless body list
experience where you and your thoughts
usually my experience it takes 20
minutes is always be thinking about my
life,
me thinking about my friendships,
my relationships,
what the fuck
you underwater.
So you just saId so much salt in the
water that when you lie in it,
you just float,
right?
So you're like half your body's above
the water like this much and everything
behind it is underwater.
So like your ears are underwater so you
can either wear earplugs if you want.
I don't usually wear earplugs,
I just get in.
But some people like earplugs,
you can just rent your ears,
you float and you're in total silence.
What's the total darkness?
Total darkness.
So it varies.
If you feel like you're flying through
space.
Like I recently got graham hancock into
it,
he just did a couple of them.
THen that's his description of what he
said.
It feels like you're in space,
you're flying because you're weightless
and as you're lying there like floating.
That's a.
That never happens in life.
We don't feel like there's anything
holding you down.
You feel like you're flying through
space and because the fact that you're
in this tank with no light coming in and
no sound,
you have no like your brain doesn't have
any work to do.
It,
doesn't have to worry about your
balance,
doesn't have to worry about moving you
around or dealing with your environment
in any way.
Nothing's coming in.
So this tank was created bY this guy who
is a.
He's a pioneer in inter species
communications with dolphins is.
It's really crazy guy called john lilly
and he did all these like really
important studies with dolphins,
like trying to teach dolphins,
human words,
trying to communicate.
All the noises are so much different
than ours,
but he did a lot of it.
While he's on acid.
He was trying to develop a bunch of ways
to get outside of the influence of the
body,
like he was being very scientific about
it and his ideas where he,
he,
we used to have like a scuba tank.
There was like,
you had a helmet on like one of those
25,000
leagues under the sea type helmet he
had.
I'm thinking like at first we were
talking about.
I was like,
yeah,
fuck,
that's what he used to have and he used
to have it where it was like hooked up
where it was on a harness and you would
be sorta just dunked in the water.
So we'll eventually you forget about the
helmet,
you forget about your body,
you just chill out and relax and the
water was the same temperature as your
skin so it becomes indistinguishable
after awhile.
Once he's got it dialed in just right.
You don't want it too hot because then
you can sweat.
We don't want it to pool your cold in
there and start shivering is a,
goldie locks 93 and a half degrees.
It's like 93 and a half.
Some people's 94.
So a,
you should do it,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's amazing.
So you got to your crib.
Yeah,
I have one.
Could I come over and try?
Sure,
absolutely.
Loved to.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But if you wanted to get one for your
house to crash definitely sells those.
So I fEel like something that should be
in every university,
it's something that should be and just a
lot of people should,
if they have the money or they have the
time or a group of people get together
and invest in it,
it's so beneficial and it's a,
it's something that's just,
it's not thought of as being an
important tool in your life,
but the ability to tune the whole world
out and just float.
That's awesome.
Oh,
you trip your balls in and out of it
because if somebody has to know,
it's real easy.
It's real easy.
It's only 11 inches of water.
So as you're lying there,
you mean you just stand up when you're
done and you just get out.
IT's nothing.
I mean you,
you can't,
you can't drown the waters.
11 inches and it's only six feet wide.
Just you touched the sides with your
hands.
yeah.
You center yourself in the middle and
relax and when you do it,
you get more and more comfortable.
Every time you do it,
the first time you do it,
it'll be a little weird.
Like everybody's described.
It pretty much says what I always have
said like the first couple times,
it's just about getting to relax,
figuring out how to relax.
Once you've done it like a few dozen
times,
then it just becomes that thing you do
just get in there and you just say that
for me is giant.
Whenever there's any issues that I'm
dealing with and he,
uh,
any problems that I have maybe
creatively even,
you know,
I like to go in there,
I'll go in there with jujitsu problems.
I'll go in there with a try,
like try to analyze someone's movements.
Like if there's a guy who like,
keeps catching me with a particular
submission,
I would,
I would go in the tank and I would try
to work out like the defense for the
submission in the tank.
Yeah.
It would go with like a specific goal in
mind because it makes your brain like
supercharged because we don't like when
I'm sitting here,
I got a super uncomfortable chair.
This is this thing called a saddle
chair,
a sally's swinging something chair.
It's super uncomfortable,
but it's really good for your back.
it makes you sit.
It makes you sit like an arrow,
you know?
Um,
but it's,
it's stupid.
Uncomfortable men.
What was my point?
No,
he was saying that like,
I completely lost my point.
We picked up the soap to show the
fucking chair.
But was I saying just before that,
none of you guys know I was listening to
three people in this room.
That's a sure sign that saying it was
very ineffective because no one
remembers that at all.
I was falling short term.
Memory's a motherfucker man.
that.
Well,
where are you talking about?
I don't know.
Oh,
we're talking about a sensory
deprivation because this,
this gives me a lot of sensory input.
It's uncomfortable.
It's like pinching my dick.
You gotta squeeze your legs together to
sit up and when you're sitting in it,
you're,
you're constantly kind of working out
your legs,
like you're pinching your legs together.
It's the only way you can sit up as if
that's the key to it.
The key to it is it's uncomfortable and
when you do sit like that,
it activates your and it's actually good
for your back and it makes my back feel
great.
It's amazing.
Let's do a three hour podcasts.
My back doesn't fuck with me at all.
Whereas if I sit in a regular chair
after like three hours,
I feel like tight.
You know,
I feel like kinked up.
This doesn't do that at all,
but there's a lot of sensory input.
I think when you're dealing with like
there's a keyboard in front of you or
did you see that light?
She,
this clock.
YoU see all these different things.
You're,
you're taking in your entire
environment,
you're feeling the gravity of your body
pulling the chair.
There's all these things that your brain
is calculating and if there was some
people next to you there were screaming
and yelling,
it'd be really hard to pay attention to
what you're saying.
Like sometimes we do these podcasts and
they'll be unloading trucks and we'll
hear the trucks.
The background.
Yeah,
we're here.
The hydraulics and the engines and shit
and it's distracting.
It makes you wish that it would go away
because then you'd be able to formulate
your thoughts without any resistance
with less resistance.
RIght?
Well,
when you're in that tank,
that is that,
that that's that state at its best
because there's nothing coming in.
There's nothing coming in.
It's just your mind.
There's nothing coming in and when you
get to that place where there's nothing
coming in,
it's beautiful.
You just,
you get a real chance to like go over
shit.
Creative stuff or personal stuff or you
know,
problems like if you play a game,
if there's anything that you do where
you constantly working on it,
like some guys play golf or some guys
you can get in that tank and just think
about all the various things.
Various aspects of anything you're
trying to concentrate on and it offers
you this window of concentration.
It's just uNavailable any other way.
I mean I definitely need to try it
because I've heard a lot about it,
but I never really knew what it was and
I didn't really know how you would go
about doing it.
Super easy.
Another thIng too,
it's like who do you ask,
you know,
and that's with anything like right now
there's less of them than they should.
There should be all over the place and
people are starting to open a business.
It can be a place where you just go,
like they have,
um,
they have them.
There's a bunch of them that are popping
up.
There's a couple of them in California
but only a couple.
But I know that,
um,
I know that the guys that run on the
map,
but thinking about starting one and I
know that crash is opening up a bigger
one in westwood.
It's just very under as far as like the
amount of demand.
It's very underutilized.
That demand is under tapped into because
I think a lot of people would like it at
burbank.
One's still there.
Yup.
Soothing solutions,
which is in burbank,
which is where I first went in like 2002
and I got hooked immediately.
Like I,
I couldn't.
I couldn't imagine that this was
something that so few people were
talking about.
You got to try it,
try it,
and then you were actually the first
person.
I might have heard about it in another
conversation too,
but you were the first person I heard
talk about it extensively in detail and
it wasn't this video.
I heard you talking about it.
One of your podcasts.
Yeah.
I won't shut the fuck up about it.
And people get mad when you have one.
I mean,
it's not just that I.
I'm telling you,
if you don't,
if you haven't tried it,
you don't know.
I'm telling you for your own good.
If I'm beating a dead horse,
I apologize,
but you just wanted to.
Lucky sons of bitches that has one in
his house.
Any luck.
There's a lot of people that do.
They do renovations to their house and
do all these different things.
they spend a lot of money and there's
don't.
That doesn't even come into the realm of
possibility.
Like we've got to get a hot tub that's
there.
People love to get hot tub on.
Mike and sue got a new hot tub.
What's just come on over and we'll go
sit in the jacuzzi.
Oh,
nice.
What is this rania.
I was about five grand more bob and they
have these fucking stupid conversations,
but if one of them said,
hey man,
I'm thinking about getting an isolation
tank,
which is like you could get one for less
than now.
I think a company called zen float,
they make one that's like really
inexpensive.
I think it's like 1700 bucks,
like the least.
The least expensive one.
It's not the same as like crashes not
even close.
It's flimsy,
but it'll work.
You know,
it's.
I dunno,
I dunno how it deadens the sound anyway,
but I guess being underwater deadens the
sound,
you know,
maybe it works great.
Maybe it's enough.
I'm looking at is definitely better than
nothing.
The kids are talking about us on twitter
a little bit.
Don't pay attention to that shit.
No,
it's great.
It's great.
It's being mean to you so you pay to
them.
They love it.
Of course they do.
They love us.
Pistol.
Fuck you up though.
You can't be doing that while you're
doing a podcast.
We never get to talk.
We'll be doing no talking on here.
Kicking it.
I wonder what how you feel right now?
You can't worry about that shit,
man.
Can't trust them.
Can't trust them with your thoughts.
Dawn of the dead.
You got a dog dead shirt.
Yeah,
man.
That's a dope fucking horror movie.
That was scary as shit.
Oh yeah.
When that movie came out and they were
going through the mall when the zombies
were wandering through the mall to
people don't know all these people today
that are so spoiled because we've had
about a billion fucking zombie movies
back then with dawn of the dead was
around when that first movie,
that movie first came out.
That was a game changer that make people
shit their pants and I think that that's
like,
you know,
I'm a big walking dead fan and you're
walking just so like,
you know,
like
greg nicotero who's just like a,
you know,
special effects,
lagging,
you know,
did a lot of the earlier special effects
in these movies,
you know,
and just to see walking dead and see
like just how they use real practical
effects and so on.
The gore is just so real looking.
Yeah.
So sick man.
I'm just a horror movie fanatic,
man.
I,
I've just been obsessed with horses
since I was a kid.
yeah,
me too.
The only thing that bugs me about the
walking dead is uniformity of their
slash or sounds.
What do you mean somebody up when
they're killing people and stuff,
you know,
where they're hacking up zombies.
The sounds are all the same.
You know what I'm saying?
A lot of variety and the sounds they
make when they cut open their heads,
man,
they get gruesome.
It's always like,
it's always the same coach.
you know what I mean?
It's like the cat sound.
Every time somebody throws something out
the window,
it's always the exact same,
like super exaggerated.
Two,
I would just like a little realism,
like sometimes when you hit someone in
the head with a bat,
it doesn't make the best sound like
sometimes you just graze them and it
doesn't have that,
that same every time.
It's like it's got a bat.
The bat specialists,
you know,
you just know well,
I've seen a lot of zombie movies pro.
I know if done correctly.
It makes it different.
Sounds like the best was 28 days later
in my opinion.
That's the best movie of all time.
Shannon,
did you see the second one?
That was fun.
That was really cool.
It was great.
Twenty eight weeks later.
That was great to look.
It was.
There was.
There was a difference in the zombies
were scary as fuck.
they ran at you and they could bite you
and if it got in you,
you would instantly turn.
You know that there were some wild
scenes.
that scene.
Spoiler alert with that chick chops or
boyfriend up with the machete.
She.
He got bit and she goes and she looks at
me.
He goes,
no,
and she just starts attacking adam with
a machete.
That is dark.
It's real life.
Fuck.
yet is joe rogan the test with real live
zombie life?
It's not real life.
It's in my eyes is real life.
Joe.
That was a fucking great movie,
man.
That was a great horror movie.
You didn't.
So you're,
you're into like the special effects
guys and everything.
You know who they are.
I just,
I'm into like,
you know,
art and now look at that as an art form.
That's how those guys do is just,
is sick.
It takes a certain level of expertise
and taste and uh,
you know,
I,
I'm just a fan of that.
Anybody that can do a horror movie with
no cgi,
I mean bravo and then still be funny and
believable.
It's like or tv show or anything.
It's,
it's,
it's not easy.
You know how it's really hard.
These guys like pat mcgee is the guy who
did the werewolf out there.
Just the walked in.
I was like,
okay,
okay.
I know I'm in the right place,
the rick baker where,
well from american werewolf in london
and one of the beautiful things about
that movie was that there was no.
cgi was all rick baker's creation and
they had to show it to you in these
little flashes.
They couldn't just show you so much of
It like they do today.
Like now.
Yeah,
the monster's look way better for sure.
But they're showing you too much.
So in showing you too much.
It's actually,
it actually looks shittier.
Like there's a lot of monster movies
where like one of the weird things about
monsters,
like a real monster movie is you see
them so briefly before they kill you,
you know,
it's like,
oh jesus,
and then you're dead.
I can sort of represented that in
american werewolf in london.
But you saw that thing for like a frame
to frame it.
You were shitting your pants.
The guy was running to the subway and
there's a brief,
like couple of frames where the
werewolf's at the bottom of the
escalator and it's down there and he's,
he's traveling up and he sees the
werewolf starting to make its way up the
escalator and shit in his pants,
just a couple seconds and it's gone and
it's like,
god damn it.
It's so much better than showing people
like a cgi,
like those movies that are kind of fun.
Underworld,
that was kind of underworld movies,
but they were will hour of screentime.
There's A wearable if you get used to
seeing it.
It's like,
you know,
if you can tease the audience and build
up that anticipation,
it's like,
you know,
because you can,
do the cgi and make you know,
the monster look more present in the
scene.
you know,
it's kind of like the people aren't
thinking about that.
Give it to them in doses,
in some movies have done it,
you know,
dope.
Like I liked cloverfield.
I thought that was sick.
I was,
the new godzilla I thought was dope.
I wasn't mad at it.
It was fun to watch,
kept surviving,
bummed me out a little bit.
I was just like,
this motherfucker has the worst luck.
yet the best luck ever.
He keeps getting these cataclysmic
situations that keeps getting out with a
bandaid.
Everybody else is dead.
This fucking dude rises from every
brushes himself off.
We got to fight god's.
Oh,
he's not freaking the fuck out that a
bridge.
Just missed it.
I know.
He's like,
we gotta get godzilla.
Could've saved my family and get
godzilla stone seen it.
Oh my god.
Is it the.
It's worth seeing just for the end
scene,
just for the fight scene between
godzilla and the other monster.
That's prettY dope.
I wasn't expecting that.
That was pretty dope.
And then it reminds you that like
godzilla is really about godzilla.
Godzilla is a hero movie.
It's like godzilla is a hero.
Godzilla is a hero.
So it's king kong.
Those are here in movies like you can't,
you can't.
They're not scary movies.
Like it's not like a monster movie,
like king kong.
You only see them in brief second.
It wouldn't work.
Like that's one of the main problems
with like special effects and a movie
like king kong.
It's like it always had to be special
effects from the 1930 movie.
Like you got to see him all the time.
It's not like this monster you briefly
see for a second and then it gets you
like the original alien.
I mean,
but that's the shit that aliens is
always going to be a classic and
original one was the best because you
put all these sought.
I think they all were kind of like that
though because in the environments that
they were at,
it was just so fucking shady like
spaceships and.
Well the second one was pretty fuckIng
dope.
That was a James Cameron one aliens.
But it was different than the first one
because the first one you barely saw
that fucking thing.
Barely saw it.
It was always sneaking by the time they
signed it would be on them and it would
kill them and that'll be it.
And then the second one,
they're everywhere and they're just
shooting them and killing them.
Like they kill them so much easier.
The first one,
it was like this super intelligent thing
that was sneaking up on you.
It was like some super genius alien and
the second one it was like this trailer
park aliens and there was a million of
them and theY were all idiots.
There were all idiots.
Like the first alien was brilliant,
so clever and sneaky to go or a new
where people were going and it would be
ambushed them.
It would hide and then the second movie
there were all dumb.
There were just jacking them.
They would just run into a room and kill
four or five of them.
The third one was my favorite.
Really would rock the rock was.
He's a nice guy,
man.
I met that dude once to show them like
one of those a talk show type things
back when he was doing that show.
He was cool as fuck.
yeah,
he seems cool,
very frIendly,
but he was a bad ass in that movie.
He was the only person that ever seen in
that whole franchise.
Go toe to toe.
That's right.
Wasn't winona ryder in that one too?
Was she in the fourth one?
How many of you?
I know that one was.
He was in the third one,
right?
Am I right?
I think so because that was the one she
killed herself.
She had the babies.
Had the baby.
Yeah.
I'm just wanting to kill the baby and
that was the one that was the one where
he was down there.
But the score up with the dude because
he ran out of ammo was like,
is that all you got?
Was like fighting them.
Yeah,
that's right.
So fucking g.
Yeah,
that didn't end well though for him,
but you know,
hey,
we don't make movIes like that and we
don't make it.
But he is poppy like in a horror movie
of.
I wouldn't even call it a horror movie.
I was like more like a spy know throw.
The first one was a horror movie.
Yeah,
but did that,
that third by the third one?
It was just more like a.
It didn't come off more.
It was more like action insight by.
But that was the only time I've ever
seen in that franchise,
if we dare called har,
where you know,
you know,
the black character goes out in such a
way where it's like,
you know,
fuck that.
And you know,
going out,
swinging like tits,
some shit like that.
Come on like an alien,
like dude,
like come on joe rogan.
You would not,
you would not score up with no alien.
Like yeah,
we do.
Do you just like shit your pants?
Yeah,
exactly.
Let it eat you.
Exactly.
It's happening.
So like if a puppy talk shit to you,
you're like,
what?
That's what it's like,
you know,
that's what the alien is life with a
person through pito.
Yeah.
And then it became aliens vs predator.
It's like,
what the fuck is you to.
It's a slow degradation from like one of
the greatest horror movies of all time.
I really scott masterpiece to like this
preposterous.
Just action,
fun film.
I mean they're fun.
I didn't watch that though.
I watched the alien versus one of them.
One of them,
I remember there was more than 1000 of
them I didn't know tournament every
year.
How many aliens vs predators know?
If I had to guess,
let me guess.
I want to say this.
Three or 4 million predators.
Don't believe this.
I remember there was one.
There's only to get the fuck out of
here.
I'm not buying that.
Maybe it was a tv show.
No,
no.
There was movies,
man.
There's transformers,
transformers,
movies.
Where there three w four.
If you count the cartoon.
Three year four.
You got the touch.
Isn't there a new one that's coming out
or something?
That's alien ware.
That's the one that just came out.
That already came out.
The marky mark one that's been in gone
already?
Yeah.
Not so good.
Wait.
No man.
You gotta bring back side of the boat?
Yeah,
he's crazy.
But he knows how to fuckIng sell shit.
Ass robots.
Formers are there.
There's,
there's the original one piece.
The new ones.
There's three.
Okay.
All right.
The one that just came out with mark
wahlberg.
That's the third one.
How many aliens?
Racist predators.
Is it just too too?
It looks like,
wow,
I would have assumed there was more,
man.
I ain't even know.
I mean,
what was the alien resident?
That was the one that was for dna.
They somehow or another got her dna.
They cloned her and it was weird cause
it's happening back.
And then there was the atheist movie,
which was weird as fuck too.
I wonder if they're going to do another
one.
I think so.
Oh yeah.
Prometheans could have been.
I don't know man.
It's hard.
Like we said,
like the idea of putting together a
movie,
just the idea of getting all those
people together.
I enjoY it.
I mean,
it wasn't the perfect saifai movie.
It wasn't the original one,
but I enjoyed it.
I thought it was fun and I love the idea
behind it.
The idea of like,
that's he introduces his dna into the,
uh,
the new virgin planet by taking some
horrible poison that breaks them down
and he dies,
falls into the water and then slowly but
surely a natural course of evolution
grows out of his dna.
And that's how people are created.
That's fascinating to me.
I mean,
it was,
I ain't never seen no shit like that.
So I,
I entertained it,
I enjoyed it.
Well,
I think that ridley scott is brilliant
and I think he's probably been thinking
about this for a long time before he
created this and I don't know who,
who wrote the screenplay,
but I would imagine all of them have
been thinking about this for a long
time.
Like if you were goiNg to like the right
way to introduce life into another
planet,
It'd be like just get a planet,
doesn't have any life and you just
inject some something,
you know,
some d and if it's a body especially
that breaks down that bodies also got
all sorts of bacteria and weird shit on
it and that's going to come out when it
dies and the bacteria starts eating his
flesh and will they be able to transmit
and,
and go to plants or other plant matter
that's on this planet.
Is there some primitive life that it can
cling to?
And,
and more with some sort of a virus.
So like,
like diseases change people,
you know,
diseases can probably change all sorts
of other things.
Viruses and bacteria slowly mutate and
morph out of this one body that comes.
I mean how much,
how far can a body go for body rotted if
there was a planet and that planet had
no biological life and he brought a body
and he just threw it there.
All it has plant life.
Is it possible that that could somehow
or another have enough fuel from eating
that body and figuring out how to
subside off plants,
that they would figure out some sort of
a way to,
to become a viable life form on a
planet.
Is that outside of the realm of
possibility that stoner talk?
is it.
I mean,
I don't know.
I mean how is the biggest too?
I don't think it's too crazy even.
And then if some other dude landed on
that same planet and then got sick from
this bacteria that was created by the
body that was left behind before then he
takes it back to his plan.
Everybody gets fucked up and they all
die.
And then the planet where the bacteria
was,
that bacteria is figured out how to form
a civilization and as wifi and they've
spread out and become.
People call themselves humans.
Yeah.
If you get too high you can think some
really stupid shit and you can talk
about it on a podcast like I just did.
But everybody's fascinated by that
subject of aliens.
The,
the idea of aliens creating people like
a movie like prometheus's.
Because I mean Like it's entertaining
that kind of play with that idea,
you know,
for a minute.
Yeah.
It's entertaining to think that
someone's gonna come visit to.
I mean everybody loves aliens.
Yeah.
I mean even given except predators,
if you live in an.
I don't fuck With aliens at all.
If you lived on an island somewhere and
you're by yourself just there,
just you sitting around.
Maybe you've got a dog,
you sit on this island,
you got plenty of food,
but your board is fuck.
Just looking at waiting for someone to
come.
Someone.
anyone just let me see a light.
I think that's kind of what's going on
with us.
It's like,
yeah,
we have each other,
but the reality is we're on some weird
round boat that's bobbing around in the
universe and we want someone to come
visit us.
What is this?
people like us are like,
hey man,
most of these people suck.
Can y'all come down here and fuck with
us?
Come take us where you teach us your
ways,
but,
but a lot of people don't suck.
RIght?
I think the real thing is figuring out
how to make less people suck and
figuring out how to way to accept to
accept people for things they've done
wrong to.
I just think is love man.
Lot more love.
Do you need that in the world?
And it ways to do it without it being
signed and so silly,
you know?
Um,
it's just something that people need to
do internally,
you know?
Yeah.
It seems like an easy thing to say,
right?
All you need is love.
But it's like,
you know what it's like to be hopeful is
a good thing.
You know?
It's a super valuable to everything.
If you're not hopeful you got nothing.
You don't mean just your attitude
determines your success in a lot of your
endeavors in life,
your attitude,
your approach that you take to it.
It's whether or not sam harris fucked me
up,
man.
I had this dude,
sam harris on the podcast and he was
talking about determinism and it's the
idea that no one has free will and that
basically everything about your
personality been formed by your
interactions with your life experiences,
your dna,
your genetics,
your neighborhood that you grew up in
and that that's just no matter what,
you do,
an inescapable and that there is no free
will.
Like every decision you make is based on
all the shit that's happening to fate is
your fate.
Well,
it's not even that you in your destiny.
I mean it's sort of been determined by
your past experiences and the chemical
interactions with those past experiences
and that you're on a path and that path
is like almost undeniable.
Which is a.
It's a weird sort of a semantic argument
to its because man,
what's going on when you decide did not
do coke anymore?
What's going on?
When you decide,
you know what,
that's it,
I'm not smoking anymore,
what,
what is going on?
Because part of me wants to say,
hey,
scott did some powerful shit.
He stepped up and he uses willpower and
he uses intelligence to realize that he
was on a bad path and that's an
admirable thing to talk about because it
inspires people who might be on a bad
path themselves to kind of like catch
your,
your momentum and you know,
and give them confidence and it gives
them confidence hearing you today with
your shit together.
All cool as fuck.
And think about you being,
you know,
this guy who was doing coke all the time
and didn't like it.
That's um,
I feel like there's gotta be something
there that made you do that.
I mean,
this idea of pure determinism is really.
And I get it.
I totally get it.
I just wonder how much of a personal
choice is just what it,
what is the force that makes a person
decide to do the right thing?
Well,
I think it goes back to what we were
talking about before.
If you kind of start from one place
where you know,
you gotta make your own way,
it just kind of makes it a little bit,
you know,
it just,
you savor it a little bit more and it
means more when you get it,
you know,
because you had to really work in a
cheap something,
you know.
But my whole thing is when I was a kid,
I was immediately looked at as someone
who wasn't gonna amount to shit.
So like,
you know,
they started talking about starting from
the bottom.
That's the bottom.
When motherfuckers look at you as a
human being and be like,
oh he,
he's not going to amount to anything.
But they know that's what teachers,
you know,
that's what your peers,
that's what certain people in the
neighborhood may think of you,
you know,
because of whatever,
whatever reason,
whatever.
You know what I'm saying off just you
just being in a certain environment,
you know.
So you already had that against you,
right?
And then you,
you don't want to conform.
You don't want to be a statistic,
you know.
And that's kind of like what my thing
was,
you know,
I just didn't want to be another nigga
out here last and shit and do you know
what I'm saying?
Like,
and,
and that was,
that was what I,
I made that choice at that time,
you know,
and,
and I knew that me making that choice
will help other people see that they can
make the choice because I was also
inspired by,
you know,
some people that were in my space that
weren't falling into other shit.
It might've been like one of my homies
that was like,
you know,
in the sports and like,
get good grades and play sports and
wasn't caught up in some shit.
And I was like,
man,
this dude got some goals here.
You know,
I might not be in the sports but this
dude right here has some type of goal
cause he don't want to turn up like this
because we got that option too.
Right.
You know.
So it's like,
it was just a lot of things I was able
to.
Then I was the youngest of four.
So,
you know,
I was able to just kind of be young and
look at my older siblings and kind of
learn what not to do and that's kind of
why they use that whole,
like I'm your big brother phrase in my
music because I feel like,
you know,
even when mistakes I've made that big
brother is supposed to do like I'm
supposed to to make some mistakes so you
can learn,
you know,
and then those kids will learn and then
they'll make their own mistakes.
Then there'll be a bunch of other kids
that are learn,
you know,
it's like a system,
you know it.
And I kinda like,
you know,
I liked that I'm that person,
I like to take that,
that whole big brother thing too,
that,
you know,
to the full extent into the music.
But I really believed that I had the
odds against me in such a way.
And I also just felt like everybody
thought I was a loser from
day one.
That was tired of feeling like that.
I was tired of people looking at me in
that way.
And I want it to finally find whatever
it was that was my own,
my calling to prove that,
you know,
because I tried everything else.
Do you think that in some ways,
like coming from a troubled background
is like almost a gift because it gives
you that burning fire or do you think
it's like a double edge sword because it
gives you that gift,
but it also gives you like this whole
that sometimes is difficult to keep
filled.
Um,
do you know what I'm saying?
Oh no,
I see what you're saying.
But it's hard to say because everybody's
circumstance is different.
You know,
like,
it could be somebody who came from money
that's still got the same like,
you know,
dna and teachings that my mom gave me
because they just have really good
parents except they came from money,
like it don't really matter.
You know what I'm saying?
And it could still be drugs in the
suburbs.
Niggas still be all these things that
one can get caught up in,
in the suburbs,
you know,
anywhere else.
So like,
I,
it's hard to say,
you know,
I just had and this,
and another thing I was talking to
somebody about,
you know,
because know I was raised,
when I think of strength,
I think of a woman I was raised by my
mom,
you know,
and that is something that I,
she's someone I always will look up to
how she just sacrificed everything and
took care of us,
you know,
on a teacher's salary.
And that for me it's like I got that
role model.
Like somebody who like could have just
been like,
damn,
I got four kids,
I need to be chasing the man and trying
to find some man to come take care of
us.
It was more like,
you know,
I got married,
it didn't work out.
Now I just need to figure it out for my
kids.
You know,
like I just had that,
you know,
and,
and I just kind of always looked up to
my mom in that way and you know,
I wanted to,
I didn't,
I didn't want to be a failure to her.
I wanted to show her that I could be
great and be as strong as she was,
you know?
That's beautiful,
man.
Yeah,
it's really a beautiful thing to say.
That's a cool story,
man.
I love that.
I,
I just feel like,
um,
there's a,
a certain amount of energy that people
get from wanting to prove other folks
wrong.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
For sure.
And uh,
it can,
it can help you in some ways.
It can certainly help you,
but I think sometimes even like when
you're talking about the benefits,
you had a cocaine,
like there's benefits to it.
It's like you could say things and do
things that ordinarily wouldn't be able
to do.
Well,
this the motivation of,
of like proving people wrong.
I'll show you,
you know,
you said I wasn't gonna be shit.
I'll show you.
Like you get to a certain point in time
that could kind of play against you to
right.
Yes.
It could backfire because then it
becomes it for me,
it becomes like an.
And I definitely did my last album.
I did my arm before last with that,
an angry I'll show you,
like full,
like villainous energy,
you know,
and I was able to make some really great
records,
but it was the most aggressive music I'd
ever made and some of it was the most
aggressive and a lot of levels,
not even in the meanwhile,
but just like,
you know,
just the music itself and that benefited
the,
you know,
what I set out to do,
it all benefited,
you know.
BuT um,
I didn't,
it wasn't the normal way I went about
making an album so it was weird,
you know,
and,
and it was something that I took a step
back with afterwards and then drop the
second album was like,
all right,
this one's not.
So um,
I don't really feel like I'm,
I'm like going,
you know,
up against the masters,
like I really have something to prove
here.
This is more just like about like just
being at some type of peace,
you know,
and just having things sorted out once
all the madness is all done and just
kinda dislike.
Now it's just like,
right,
right.
You know,
and that's why I did indicat another
satellite flight because I feel like in
the cup was me just figuring out how to
produce,
you know,
and make records and then satellite
fight was me having it mastered and
finally putting together something that
was just like fine tuned,
you know,
but to,
in a different structure where I have
like some instrumentals and then you
know,
you know,
the kind of like interludes and then
records that just completely formatted
in different ways.
Maybe not the three verse two hook
formula,
maybe just one long verse in one outro
and you know,
maybe know who get all,
maybe no drums for the first minute and
30 seconds,
but there's like wraps,
you know,
just experiment and then try and things,
not that I had that expertise.
We're creating a record,
you know.
Did you ever,
um,
listened to the brand new heavies?
I know some records here,
the brand new heavies did this rap thing
where there,
god was trying to remember the name of
it.
Um,
there's a,
but it was along those lines like very
experimental.
And this is like back in the early
nineties,
they did like kool g rap did one of them
and it did it like some like actual
music behind it.
It was pretty interesting stuff.
But I remember that and I remember
thinking like,
man,
like why don't more people do weird shit
with music.
Like how many people are thinking the
way you're thinking?
Like saying like,
okay,
how about we just do no drums for like
the first minute and a half and then
just start rapping and then the drums
kick it.
Like these kinds of things where you
just like coming up with a,
like just a different approach.
Slightly different entry.
I think people are just a little scared
that they'll lose the audience's
attention,
which is the very real fear.
It's,
I get it,
you know,
it also goes back to what I was saying,
I've just been blessed with a family
that like,
you know,
it's into what I'm doing no matter what,
uh,
and that's,
that's just dope,
you know.
But the average artist,
no,
theY can't just experiment.
And this fear where they might not sell
records.
And then that's bad for business and
this is a business,
you know,
um,
so,
you know,
um,
it's,
it's understood why most guys don't
really do it,
you know,
I would like to see people do it.
I feel like there's,
that's not an excuse.
I feel like there's a way where people
can be a little bit more creative and
push the envelope a lot more with the
music,
uh,
where it fits in,
in a,
in a way that makes sense.
And it's true to their,
their art.
Um,
in their formula.
I feel like,
yeah,
there's always a way to try something
new and be innovative and bring
something different to the table
if anybody wants to check out that.
That brand new heavies that I was
talking about,
it's called heavy rhyme experience.
Uh,
and it was the brand new heavies.
It was 92 way back in the day when I
was,
I was living in New York and my friend,
goddammit,
trying to remember his name,
stand up,
comedian told me about them.
He goes,
you gotta listen to this shit.
These guys are doing some weird stuff.
They did a duel with kool g rap.
They did a,
one of them with a gang.
Starr was pretty bad ass that,
a bunch of different collaborations.
So like jazz singers was like,
rap,
like serious,
like best of the class back then.
Hardcore rappers rapping over their,
uh,
their ride or their music.
It was pretty cool.
My law.
Yeah,
but your point about having the fan base
that allows you to fuck around and
practice and take chances.
That is huge,
isn't it?
Like this ability that you know,
they,
they like you as a person as well as
like your music so that.
And they want,
they want to see where you go with it.
You're always going to do your best.
No,
it comes from a pure place to know.
I'm like,
they know me as the top table,
say no,
I'm just trying to make some cool shit
that they can connect with and that's
the extent every time it doesn't go
beyond that and the minute it tries to
just starts to get frustrating,
like start thinking about a radio record
to please somebody at the label.
Then it gets frustrating.
If I started thinking about this and
that,
this and it gets frustrating if I keep
it just based on like,
amen,
this sounds gnarly and let's make sure
we not too trippy and it's make sure
it's not to this and not do that.
But uh,
effortless combination of everything all
at once,
you know,
and,
and that's really what these past couple
of years for me have been like just
mastering that technique is a producer
and um,
you know,
really,
really just going all out creatively and
just trying new things because I also
internally don't feel like I have
anything else to prove,
um,
as a musician.
But I,
I have that itch,
you know,
like I need to create.
I feel like that's like working out for
me.
It's like doing reps and stand mentally
fit,
creatively fit,
you know?
Um,
so when it comes time to do an album,
I got some new powers I've acquired in
the past year,
just like,
you know,
from just dicking around in the studio
for a couple of months is going everyday
making beats.
Whether I'm in the studio for five hours
or two hours,
I'm making something I'm making at least
like on average I make about in the
studio,
I'm making at least two to four beat
today.
And when I say beats,
I'm talking about completed,
sequenced instrumentals that I could
make records are so,
like not just some sit.
I started a little bit and then it's
kind of cool and I'll get back to it
later.
I have probably like a baker's dozen of
those in one session,
but I'll have like four that are
officially.
Like all these jams are dope.
I'm going to sit and live with these and
see what comes up.
So when you sit down to write music,
do you,
do you sit down and do you have an idea
in your head or do you just let it come
to you while you're there?
Like how do you know how to start?
Um,
it,
it comes different every time.
It doesn't,
um,
it depends.
It can be a baseline that I'm thinking
of that inspires me or it could be me
not have anything in my mind.
And just going through the sounds a or
it could be like,
you know,
a rhythm I heard or you know,
anything,
it could be a movie I'm watching,
I like to,
you know,
produce while I'm watching movies with
the sound off,
um,
in,
that kind of helps me with scoring,
you know,
when I get into the scoring and you
know,
doing that as my next step.
I want to get more into scoring movies
and sound design.
Um,
but it's all,
for me,
it's all just experimentation and just
seeing what happens and you know,
it's not any pressure.
And when you hear a beat,
like when you're making a beat and
you're creating it,
you hearing lyrics.
Are you hearing?
Yeah,
I'm hearing.
I mean here's,
you know,
when I,
when I'm hearing something I hear a
completed right?
So when I'm starting to record and I
feel like I got some of my or I saw
like,
I feel like in this back to what you
were talking about because you know,
I feel like,
you know,
time doesn't really exist.
So an hour from now it's happening right
now.
Right.
So there's songs that are created that I
haven't made yet,
so when I'm in the studio I feel like I
have this small like peek into this
other world and this window that I can
hear the song,
but it's my job in the present to find
the pieces to make it so.
And sometimes it might come out exactly
like what I'm hearing and sometimes it
might not,
but it's never,
it's never really spot on.
You're not just here glimmers of what
the song completed sounds like until
it's completed and then it's just
everything's perfect.
But that's how I can sit there and
listen to a mix and be like,
something's off.
Because in my completed version,
you know,
it's like a coloring book.
Every record starts off in one way,
just blank and I'm just filling in all
the colors and then there's one color
still missing.
You know,
that's what's happening in the final,
in the ninth end.
And you know,
when we're mixing the album,
I mean there's still some colors that
just not in there yet.
And then I'm going through
sounds and I find the colors and
everything's full and I'm cool or I
might not find the exact color,
but some close enough I'm fine.
And like that's literally where it's at,
where you have to make the executive
decision,
like,
all right,
I'm done with this or I'll be sitting
for another two weeks trying to sit with
this mix because I'm really anal about
it and if I don't just back away and let
it be,
you know,
we'll never hear any news.
That's a fascinating insight into the
creation of music.
So I don't,
um,
I don't know anYbody that does that
like,
well where they could tell me about the
entire process from the beginning to
end.
So it's interesting to get a window into
that world because I always wondered,
I always wondered,
like,
I know jj never writes his lyrics down.
It keeps them all in his head.
Do you do that or do you actually write
them down somewhere?
I'm not.
Sometimes I'm sometimes.
I mean,
a lot of hooks are in my head,
but I need to write certain things down
to make sure I'm making sense.
I used to do a lot of my earlier stuff
just off the dome,
just freestyle and shit,
you know?
And sometimes that works good with
melodies.
I do that a lot.
I'll go in there and just flows and try
different things like that and melodies.
But it's really just a combination.
It's never the psych,
you know,
always like writing off the dome,
like some ballots out.
Right?
Completely off the dome.
You know,
I don't need paper for a ballot,
but like turn off the dome.
Yeah,
that's a great term.
I'm gonna use that from now on.
Whenever there's a joke that I have this
written down anywhere it's going to be
offered dome that that was the end.
I feel like that it kinda like,
you know,
gets people to understand that this is
something,
this,
this spontaneousness of it,
you know.
Is that some turn that rappers use all
the time or is that your term off the
dome?
Is that yours?
Yours.
I like to say I know the guy came up off
the dome.
It's a very popular phrase amongst it
all came out of kid company.
I'll take it.
They get.
I'll start spreading that rumor.
You're essentially you're open,
whatever.
Which way ever comes.
You just show up,
you show up and you put in the work you
put in the work creating to be to put in
the work,
come up,
coming up with lyrics,
whatever way it comes up,
whether it comes up all in your head
when it comes up,
writing it down on paper and the
sessions are really me and my engineer
in and occasionally I have like my
brother from another mother,
dr jean is coming through who was in a
band that I came up with a couple of
years ago that you know,
we kind of just put together because we
wanted to try something outside of the
world.
We were already making music in,
you know,
it's,
this sessions are really small.
It's not like I got 20 dudes in there.
They're kind of sad sessions were really
sad and probably not sad.
Why?
Always wondering,
I feel bad for me like,
oh got nobody in town.
But then,
but then like,
you know,
like I'm in there like a mad scientist.
Like,
you know,
I'm inventing,
it's not like,
you know,
an inventor don't get 20 motherfuckers
in his lab.
Why he invented shit niggas is still is
shit.
or they'll,
you know,
rack focus and you know,
distract him.
He got.
I find that when you have your friends
in the studio,
you got,
you know,
a couple guys on worldstar,
couple of guys on twitter,
a couple of guys over here and
everybody's talking about what's going
on over here and what's going on in here
and you're trying to write this song.
You get distracted.
You like,
what happened all hell naw,
that's funny.
Bunny,
next to you know,
it's two hours have gone by.
You still working on this record,
you had some last.
But when you came to the studio for is
not done yet.
Right?
You know,
and there's money being spent and it's
time.
Time is of the essence.
This is what we hustled and worked hard
for.
You know?
And I have to,
I had to remind myself is like,
man,
this has turned into a fucking party.
Like we're here for work.
So I also have this like really gnarly
work ethic.
Like,
cause I've been working since I was 15.
My first job was wendy's.
I remember why I wanted to work.
It was because I wanted my own shit.
I was tired of asking my mom for stuff
and also didn't think it was fair to ask
my mom for stuff because I know we
didn't have much.
So you know,
I just at work for me is always like one
of those things that's very important.
Yeah.
But like there was also some jobs that I
didn't fucking take seriously,
like american apparel,
you know,
where I was coming in late and I didn't
give a shit.
And then like when my boss fired me,
like he took me to this office and kind
of told me.
And,
and when he said he's like,
I'm gonna have to let you go.
I was like,
yeah,
I figured that,
you know,
because I didn't give a fuck,
it was like,
now I can go to the studio.
Well it's probably work and like work on
my craft and then maybe find a better
paying job.
You know,
it doesn't have me in the fucking
basement of some buiLding,
you know,
sweating my ass off for clothes.
Everybody says you should always do your
best at every job you do.
A champion in life as a champion and
everything they do.
So if you're going to mop floors,
do your best to my peers,
my the fuck out of floors.
That's great on paper.
But the reality is when you're a young
man,
it's sometimes it's good to fuck off at
something.
So you know,
you don't ever want to do that again.
They fire you and then you learn and
there's some,
there's some value in that.
It's unfortunate,
but we don't all learn the best way.
Sometimes we got to get fired from
american apparel.
At least I didn't get fired for like
stealing something.
I got fired for being a shitty
landscaper,
scalp and people's lawns that fuck
somebody's emotions and that would hurt
my feelings if somebody just was like
the word around town that I've been,
you know,
my main bread and butter I've been
doing,
investing my life in shitty yet.
Yeah.
I wasn't invested in being atlanta
mayor.
Not toddler boy landscaper.
Yeah,
I know.
I know what you're saying,
man.
It says there's a completely different
thing when you're creating your own
stuff when you're working for yourself,
then it's like a focus,
like an obsession almost type focused.
Like the laser beam.
I love that term.
The lab too.
That's one of my favorite terms for the
rap,
the rap world.
They love talking about being the lab,
creating material who are like an
inventor scientist,
you know,
and it's,
it's kinda like I treated and every
sense of the word in every sense of
that,
that term.
I asked him,
no lab.
It's like where I'm working,
it's working and almost don't like
playing around and in the studio like
that,
like because it is a place for work,
it is an office,
especially if you're trying to write,
if you're trying to write things there
too as well.
He tried to write lyrics and dudes are
all jumping around and not even know
what if I'm not even just me sitting
there and I might not have an idea yet.
even if I might just eating silence.
Right,
right,
right.
I might just need fucking silence for a
little bit.
Yeah,
I don't,
I've never been to any sort of a
recording studio where anybody was doing
anything like serious like that.
But I would imagine it's very difficult
to avoid the party.
It's like,
hey,
we're in studio and guys come to visit
you come on by,
come to visit.
We did that.
So it's like I did that now I've been
doing that since like 22,
23 going to studios and having those
moments with the buttons because in the
beginning it's like you want your boys
around.
So I kind of got that out of my system
and now it's like,
all right,
30 year old scott goes with studio by
himself.
He's got his book bag,
he's in there for maybe five,
six hours and then he goes home.
That's smart.
You know what I'm saying?
And then friday night,
you know like in,
in,
in bed by like 11,
1130 kapow fucks her.
That's beautiful.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No may man.
That's how you get shit done.
That is how you get shit done.
I'm just cycle those music videos
though.
When they show the recording studio,
it's always a giant table.
There's like all those little switches
that nobody understands.
Maybe you mixing board.
Everybody's everybody standing in front
of all the switches and then everybody's
partying.
Everybody's in the background,
having a good time.
But that could also be when the album's
done and they're celebrating it because
that's what also happens.
like when I'm done with the say that's a
finished maybe eight songs and I feel
like I've got the album like and I just
need maybe a couple more jams.
You start inviting people to come here.
What you got,
so you have those moments too,
so you might see that happen and,
but,
but there's a year and a half of just
studio by myself before that happens,
you know,
like I don't really.
And maybe a case that had one or two
friends,
you know,
maybe some one of my director friends
or,
or um,
my fellow actors.
So I just kinda want who have never
really got a chance to be in the studio,
come by and just see,
get to experience,
but they're not in.
They're distracted me there just
watching and paying attention and want
to just be a fly on the wall,
see how it works.
Yeah.
Well a lot of people are really curious
about it because it's a,
it's almost a sort of a mysterious type
of creativity if people aren't involved
in.
Especially the creating of music is such
a cultural,
uh,
it's such a cultural influence.
So sort of powerful Influence like music
has.
It inspires people.
Like when you listening to music at the
gym,
it can make you work out better.
Like you put your headphones on and you
play some awesome songs.
You don't give a fuck that you're on
some stupid stamp machine,
like a hamster.
He just keep going.
Yeah.
And the music you,
you liked the music so much.
you get into it and it's only,
it's in your head,
drowning out everything else.
Sometimes you don't realize how heavier
breathing until you know,
you
take the earplugs out,
you're like,
holy shit,
be getting it in.
Working here.
It's because of nothing else like hits
you like that.
Like people's words.
They don't sustain that way.
You can't like read incredibly
passionate essay and it sustains you
through a workout like that.
Like it needs to be just something that
like this.
Nothing like music in that respect.
It has,
it has an impact that very few things
do.
So that,
that process of creating it is always
fascinating and mysterious to people
like me that don't have any musical
talent at all.
Yeah,
I see it.
Um,
I,
I just approached it in a different way
because I'm just,
I do feel like I'm just,
every time I'm in the studio it's like,
um,
me just,
you know,
trying to create the uncreated and it's
a very private thing sometimes,
you know,
I want to,
I want to be able to,
you know,
have my privacy when I do that.
Right.
Yeah.
No,
I totally.
Do.
You do all your writing and everything
and the studio or do you sometimes sit
at home?
Oh,
it comes whenever,
man.
I'll be in the shower.
Do you have any of the shower?
I'm thinking of some shit,
you know.
Do you ever use that a note app on the
phone,
on your phone?
Were you talking to it?
I'm recording memos.
Yeah,
a lot.
A lot of the time.
Not even that.
I mean the note app,
you know,
you can talk to it
had a voice recognition.
No,
no,
no.
I just kinda see if I'm recording
something,
some melody.
I'm thinking of something,
I'm not thinking of wraps like days.
It's less about that now and it's more
about like,
like just melodies and coming up with
songs and structure.
You want to hear the sound and then the
lyrics come next Because the music is
just going to tell me what to say,
you know?
Wow.
That's fucking wild.
That's so cool.
Now how much of your creation is done
under the influence of marijuana?
Man,
I don't smoke to create.
I've come up with a lot of shit sober
sometimes when I'm fresh.
Waking up in the morning,
like sometimes the most ideas at like
8:00
AM.
Sometimes people say that
writers like Stephen King I believe does
all of his writing in the morning.
I think he doesn't like nine to noon
every day.
Yeah.
It's like man,
I'm fresh in the morning with something,
some melody and it usually comes,
is walking through the house making
breakfast and you know,
uh,
it can be whenever dropping a deuce,
you know,
I come up with just melodies here and
there and I record them all if something
really catches me because If I don't
record them immediately then I lose
them.
So I,
you know,
I got to record them somehow,
but it's,
it's very,
um,
I'm always,
I'm always thinking about music as much
as like I like to deny it and go shoot a
movie and shit and,
you know,
I always think about music.
I'm obsessed with the idea of just
making,
you know,
the most beautiful songs that like,
really make people feel some type of
comfort or some type of understanding
because the world is so fucked.
And
uh,
you know,
I just really am obsessed with that
idea.
I think I'm always going to be
anomalous,
just trying different,
different ways of doing that.
You know.
Uh,
we did the rap shit,
we did the rock album.
Now I'm just trying to be disliked weird
instrumentalist,
you know,
and I don't really know when that's
going to be,
but I'm just really,
I guess in the process learned not to
produce better too,
which is something that I've been trying
to.
I always want to be better.
So it's good to be learning and getting
better as I'm creating.
Do you do any other things other than
music?
Do you have any other hobbies or things
that like I'm also get locked into a,
I like design and sometimes like a,
I wouldn't look at myself as like a
fashion designer,
but you know,
if an opportunity comes around I'll do a
collaborative to you like design
clothes,
like clothes?
Yeah,
like I've done a,
about five t shirt collaborations with
bathing ape.
Um,
I used to work there.
That was my last job before I got
famous,
you know,
so like I have roots back in New York
and that was pretty much one of those.
The only job I've really kept in touch
with and you know,
that I went baCk to and,
and you know,
did some things for the fans.
So you just seemed to creating shit.
It doesn't,
you know,
it really for me,
I'm starting to write a little bit more.
It's just staying creative,
right?
Like realized like a book or like blog
entries.
Like what do you mean?
Like a tv show or tv shows,
horror movies,
ideas I've had in my head for awhile.
I'll just start jotting them down and
you know,
just everything right now.
It's just me expressing whatever comes
to mind,
you know,
uh,
anything that creatively strikes me.
Yeah.
See,
that's a dream job for people to be able
to just come up with things all the
time.
Let's work on creating your entire day
is spent mostly just concentrating on
creating.
I'm not doing anything with those things
yet,
but it's,
it's stimulating,
you know,
it doesn't mean that I'm gonna have some
tv show tomorrow or anything or it's
just for me,
it,
it just,
it's stimulating,
you know,
and,
and shit knowing me I'll fuck around and
my right,
the next shit,
you know,
like something that yet or something
that could lead me to some showing who
knows,
but um,
and it probably also helps you,
your,
your creativity and the other areas as
well.
Right.
but then on top of that,
I was the king of being like,
oh,
I have this idea,
but nah,
that's not for me.
Or no,
I couldn't do that.
Um,
music is my thing.
No,
I couldn't do that.
So now I'm past that.
Now there's nothing if it pops into my
mind and I can fucking do it because I
thought about it for a reason.
So now it's just about finding time for
certain projects and I'm not no rush.
You know,
I worried about being pigeon holed,
you're saying no,
I think I think I've done enough strong
arm and let me get my space as an artist
where I can kind of do whatever I want
now at this point she reached out to me.
I just want us to be good though.
Like,
don't get me wrong.
I'm always feeling like I'm vulnerable
to make some bullshit though.
I don't feel like I'm invincible.
and I think a lot of artists do get to
that point.
They feel invincible.
Like I am very capable of making some
weak shit.
Y'all motherfuckers don't hear it,
you know,
and he asked because I'm sitting there
and making sure that this is not weak
shit.
Scrapping the ones that are and,
and,
and working on the ones that started off
week,
but you know,
making sure that they were where they
needed to be before you heard it.
Um,
do you have the other,
like you gotta know when to abandon
them?
Oh yeah.
You all know when that abandoned some
shit immediately and certain feelings
you get,
you know when some shit is the right one
and when it's not this guy.
There's jokes like that too.
Very similar.
Yeah,
very similar.
Some of them you just gotta let go.
Yeah.
And you can't infer songs is,
it's much more emotional to let go some
shit that you like because it might be
on the right track to being something
gnarly.
Like she put it on the shelf.
Maybe say key visited.
Yeah.
I go back every year.
I go back and listen to the shit that I
made the year before.
Do you categorize them?
Do you,
do you make notes or do you use.
They're all numbered.
Just number.
you just say you go back and you go,
okay,
this is from 2013.
Let me just listen to what I was doing.
MY uh,
my engineer,
I'll just tell him,
pull up everything and we'll just listen
to things one by one flag.
The ones that are good and are there
ones that You know,
because that's the thing,
you always got to give yourself a break
and uh,
it's always good to listen to stuff with
fresh years.
I find uh,
And also,
uh,
to just gIve you your,
your brain a break because for me,
I'm sitting in the studio for hours
listening to the same old shit,
like the same old beat,
you know,
that you're workIng on,
so it's kinda like you need to back off
of second and like I like to,
you know,
work on a record,
bounce him,
whatever,
you know,
bouncing means,
kinda compressing all those sounds to
one track to make that mp3.
That's what you bounced out a fire,
that's what you guys get on your ipod is
a bounced down file of all of all the
files.
So I bounced down everything everywhere.
The ones that I feel like we're close to
being finished or reasonable enough for
me to listen to and write to.
and um,
I won't listen to him that night.
I'll wake up the next day and while I'm
making breakfast I might listen to them
that with fresh ears and I'll be like,
aw shit.
Most of the time it's like,
whoa,
this is dope.
Because the night before I'm just saying
hi,
this shit sucks.
I don't know,
I'll listen to it tomorrow,
you know,
because I've been in our.
I've been in the studio for hours by
myself and I don't have nobody to tell
me like,
yo,
that shit is fresh.
It's just me and my own expertise and
just like right now I think this is all
shit,
but I'll bounce it down and I'll just do
it tomorrow,
see how I feel,
and almost every time I do that,
if I bounce it down it's like dope and a
lot of this shit can be for someone else
and not for me.
Do you?
It's the thing about music too,
it seems like when,
when there's a song that I really like
at any genre,
it's like I really like it.
I like it at first and then I started
really liking it.
When I keep hearing it,
I hear it a bunch of times and as out
here,
like the fourth or fifth time.
That's what I'll really get into it.
Yeah,
and it's interesting how music does
that.
Like there's,
there's songs that you need hear a bunch
of times.
That's why people don't like new shit.
Like at the rolling stones go on tour.
Like they let her play those fucking
classics.
Nobody wants to hear some weird shit.
Even writing keith,
they may,
I learn,
I learned the hard way,
you know,
you go out and you do coachella and it's
like alright,
I got fucking coachella to do this.
Come with the hits,
let's give them this,
give them the joints.
Didn't want to hear you know,
I'm not going to go out and coachella
and be like,
alright guys,
so I know you guys know these songs as
they are produced on the album but we're
doing them all tonight and I'm doing
them all in different key so they won't
even be formatted how you remember him.
But I promise you,
you have me tonight on this stage for at
least an hour and a half and it's just
the worst show ever,
you know?
Yeah.
When you go and do a new show,
like if it's totally new thing.
Do you do or smaller clubs you fuck
around with like rock clubs?
Were you talking about like,
like if you're gonna work the first time
you're going to do a,
a live perform any of your new material
tour tour.
Because the tour is like,
for me it's the fan club,
you know,
I could go up there and fumble is many
times I want all night and my fans are
just like,
it's all good.
This clubhouse right where you're
supposed to fuck up,
you know when you go and do coachella,
there's no time,
there's no time to fuck up.
Everybody's watching.
It's like the clubhouse.
We dick around.
It's like,
you know,
when a comic goes to like the,
the,
the um,
the club used to do standup at before he
blew up because he knows those people.
He could be himself there and can try
new jokes.
You know,
that's the same deal.
That's how I approach tour.
You know,
I don't let press in unless they buy a
ticket.
You want to come to my show and fucking
buy a ticket because most of the time
you get the press,
their ticket in their writing and
talking shit.
You're giving motherfuckers a free pass
to come see your shelter.
They can talk shit.
It's like,
no asshole.
You want to talk shit about my show,
you're going to pay for it.
Can't get any attention unless they talk
shit.
That's a,
that's a big issue with folks.
But it's like a,
like,
you know,
whatever the case may be,
I'm going to make you work hard to get
in there to talk shit because it is a
fucking membership.
It's like the only people I want in my
concert of people that really give a
shit about what we're doing as artists,
you know,
and,
and you know,
understand me as a human being,
you know,
so say a very psychedelic point of view.
Yeah.
I mean,
because it is at the end of the day like
we were talking about before,
it's all an experience,
you know,
and,
and show is even more so because it's
bringing the songs to life and I'm
there.
It's like a play theater.
Like I'm out there,
I'm,
I'm the showman for tonight and I'm
taking you to a place.
It's kinda like leave your worries
behind.
Yeah.
It's like I don't really want kids to
know the average hip hop show.
It's like you see your favorite artists
come out at best performing it hits.
They're almost there but you can't touch
them.
But it's just dope to,
to know that you're in the same building
with them.
And then that's the end of it.
And that's what you take.
It's like man,
it was,
we were in the nosebleeds but it was
really nice.
Was there tonight would that my favorite
rapper or whatever.
This shit with me.
It's more therapy.
I'm confessing some things through song.
You see me,
you know,
confess These things.
You see the emotion as unperforming,
you know?
And then there's kids out there that are
connecting with it in such a way where
it's like,
man,
I already connect with this dude,
but he's performing it in such a way
where he means it even more.
He's singing it in a way where he means
that even more in this environment,
you know,
it's like,
it's a different experience.
And I love giving people that
experience,
you know,
I love connecting with them in a way
where,
you know,
everybody at that concert is paying
attention and they're there because
they,
they want to experience something.
Right.
You reached out to me about people
asking questions about psychedelics
fielding questions about psychedelic.
Yeah.
What was the,
what was the motivation behind that?
Uh,
just I saw a tweet from a young man,
he hit me up and he was just simply
asked me,
uh,
you know,
how much you should take some shrooms.
And I,
I don't know,
I was just,
I just saw it.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
I gave him a response and I didn't think
nothing of it.
But then I saw a lot of people responded
and I was like,
oh,
this is cool.
And other people were asking me
questions and then I was like,
holy shit,
this could be bad,
could be really bad.
But it's like,
you know,
what the imu,
big brother's shit,
like if they're gonna do drugs and they
want to know about,
at least asked me to come to me,
you know,
I'll give you the,
the real shit,
you know,
you want them to ask.
Somebody asked me,
um,
and that's kinda how I looked at it and
it ended up being this thing.
But then I know that you talk about
psychedelics and you have specifically
talked about dmt because I answered the
question about dmt and that's why I was
like,
man,
we should talk about this with joe,
you know,
because I know that I,
I mean I can't sit down with anybody and
talk about dmt.
Even some of my friends,
I've told them that I've done it and
they have like looked at me in a way
where it's like,
you know,
it's like,
whoa,
you did.
It's a game changer man.
But that lets me know that there's
people that don't understand it and
they're not educated about it.
And so they just kind of hear these
stories and that's also why I was like,
man,
it would be dope to if we just sat down
and talked about it and educate some
people because I just know it's,
I mean,
even some people are scared of acid.
It's a scary thing,
you know,
I tell people I remember this is a true
story.
Um,
I hope so.
This is kind of like one of those
things.
I'm not throwing this kid under the bus,
but,
you know,
it's just a reality.
Um,
I was at coachella,
we were backstage,
ran random,
the wiz khalifa,
uh,
you know,
I see him often and he was telling me he
was doing shrooms or whatever and
experiment with shrooms.
And I was like,
oh man,
you should do acid.
And he was just like,
no.
I was like,
oh man.
It's like the training wheels are
fucking psychedelics and shit,
you know.
And it's likE,
he's all,
man,
I'm fucking with that though.
Just you can just tell that it was just
maybe,
maybe he might've known somebody who had
a bad trip or he heard some bad things,
but like there was like fear and I was
like,
oh man,
it's just people.
People are kind of like taken back when
you say you do acid sometimes.
And even when I talk about it on
twitter,
people would be like,
whoa,
chill.
You want some other shit?
and it's like man,
like,
I mean,
well that's the one would be really
crazy.
Yeah.
But I don't.
You can go crazy drinking too much.
Yeah.
It's.
So I don't really.
You've never had a bad trip on acid.
Yeah.
But it wasn't because of me was because
I let some other motherfucker come into
the situation that wasn't ready with his
shit,
you know,
some people come in and try to act like
they do this and don't do thIs and you
know,
you have situations like that.
But I've heard bad trip and you got
dragged along because you gotta you
gotta make sure everybody's cool and you
want to,
you know,
help people out.
You don't want to leave,
nobody abandoned and I feel like that's
the big thing with psychedelics is if
you're doing it with people,
no matter if you know them well or not,
you don't want to really leave nobody
hanging,
you know,
and you want to write.
You want to try to find that common
ground because everybody tripping,
you know?
And it's like,
you know,
everybody at the end of the day we're
tripping and it's scary because somebody
gets to be like one minute he was trying
to kill me.
What?
No,
think back.
I've never had no shit like that and I'm
pretty sure people have dealt with that
though.
You know,
that's the thing.
But acId is always the hardest stories.
Like we were talking about pink floyd,
like the dude from pink floyd,
which,
which one of those guys went fucking
crazy.
What the fuck's his name?
Jeremy.
You don't know.
Yeah.
One of the dudes from pink floyd went
fucking crazy.
that's what shine on you.
Crazy diamond was about him.
That song was about him going fucking
crazy from doing too much asset.
Hold on,
shine on you crazy.
Diamond.
I know part of the information,
I don't want to quote like I know it
all.
Yeah.
In wikipedia days,
the man.
Yeah,
it was written.
Okay.
Shine,
shine on you.
Crazy.
Diamond is a nine part pInk floyd,
nine part pink floyd composition,
which is what andre waters,
Richard Wright and David Gilmore,
and it's attributed to former band
members.
Sit barrett.
Syd barrett was the one who went bond.
Nan was allegedly allegedly,
but that album cover was,
is so fucking sick too.
Shaking his hand and dudes on fire.
Yeah.
So fucking gnarly.
For real.
Yeah.
He,
um,
apparently,
I don't know if that's true,
the whole lsd thing,
but through the it says this is the
wikipedia.
It says throughout late 1960 for um,
for barrett,
for syd barrett throughout ninth,
late 1967 in the early 1968,
barrett's behavior became increasingly
erratic and unpredictable.
Partly as a consequence of his reported
heavy use of psychedelic drugs.
most prominently lsd.
Many reports described him onstage
drumming one cord through the entire
concert or not playing at all.
Had a show at the fillmore in san
francisco during a performance of
interstellar overdrive.
Barrett slowly detuned his guitar.
The audience seemed to enjoy such
antics.
Unaware of the rest of the bands.
Consternation interviewed on the pat
boone showed during the tourist sids
replied to boone's question was blank
and totally mute stair according to nick
mason.
Nick,
what?
Sid wasn't into moving his lips that
day,
so he was just.
He was just going.
He was my hero.
He went out there for whatever reason.
I mean,
I don't use my hero.
Yeah,
he might've lost it.
Shit.
who knows?
Or he might've just got tired of was
like,
fuck this probably.
Yeah,
probably on acid all the time and just
couldn't realize he was quitting pink
floyd for acid.
That new girl shoes is still.
He was still in that old relationship.
well,
we were talking about cigarettes earlier
and in a world where cigarettes are
legal and they kill half a million
people in this country alone every year,
it's preposterous to think that we're
too much of a group of fucking babies to
deal with psychedelics.
We need like centers,
we need centers,
we have educated people with degrees and
understand that the human body doctors
who could administrative people can take
care of people and have them in these
really comfortable environments where
people go and they they,
they have the possibility in a
professional setting of experiencing
these things and that should be a part
of normal human culture because you've
benefited from it.
I've benefited from it.
Brian has kind of benefited from it.
Debatable as he holds up the cigarettes.
Camels smokes.
Camels.
Silly bitch.
Do you think you can get hypnotized?
I don't think hypnotized or I don't
think I can get hypnotized now to smart.
Yeah,
I think I would just think about it the
whole time.
Overthink about ira.
This guy's trying to hypnotize me right
now.
I could hear his voice.
All right.
I don't know.
I think.
I think you could do it bro.
They say iowasca is one of the best ways
to quit.
Iowasca supposed to be like a really
good way to quit smoking with anything.
If you want to wake up and I'm alive,
thank god,
but you go through it,
you go through the journey and it's just
so self examined.
Tory.
Even the regular dmt trips I've had,
they're intensely self examine it,
like the,
the,
the insight that you have in your own
life and your own world,
your own mind.
It's just,
it's,
it's scary because it's so.
It's so clear.
The clarity.
So bizarre.
It freaked me out,
man.
I'm,
I'm not gonna lie,
not done.
You know,
I've done my fair share of asset.
I'm big on psychedelics.
Dmt,
some next level shit,
but I've had nothing like this.
And you try to explain
it and you can't because there's nothing
you could just know.
You can't find the words to explain
sometimes what you see,
uh,
you know,
you a little bit more educated about it
than I am.
You could probAbly find the words,
you know,
like sometimes you fucking talk like a
scientist and she following like,
but you know,
bullshitting.
But you know,
at the same time,
like for people that might not be
educated and still hard for me to,
you know,
put the words what I saw,
but you know,
the reality is,
is what you're seeing is everything
literally melt down and reconnect,
deconstruct and reconstruct around you
and your eyes are wide open.
and it literally,
for me,
that was the only thing that freaked me
out.
The fact that my eyes weren't closed,
but my environment was completely
altered immediately,
almost before I could even exhale all
the smoke before I was even leaning back
on my couch.
I mean the room rearranged itself and
became something else in it.
I felt happy.
Graham hancock has a very fascinating
way of looking at it and what he thinks.
The way he described it to me,
I never heard anybody describe it this
way before,
but it made total sense.
He said,
everyone says you're taking drugs and
it's distorting your perception of
reality,
and that's what you're saying.
he goes,
that is a possibility.
Another possibility is that like a
telescope needs to be tuned in to see a
far off star.
That what you're doing by taking this
chemical that your brain already makes,
you're tuning into something that's
ordinarily impossible for you to see and
that there is this dimension that is
around you all the time and it is filled
with intelligent entities and he said,
we must consider that that is also a
possibility and that is a fascinating
way of looking at it because we really
don't know what's happening and the
people that aren't blown away by it or
just the people who haven't done it.
If you've done it and you're not blown
away by it,
I don't understand.
You know,
maybe There's supposedly some people who
don't have a reaction to dmt.
There's a small percentage of people
that try it where nothing happens.
Went two separate occasions where a
first time it didn't work for me and in
the second time it did.
Was the first time bad stuff or do you
just not think the first time we didn't
administer it?
Right.
And then the second time it was
downright.
The second time it was the second time
was also I hit it extra hard because I
was a mistake.
It's going to work this time,
so I had this really like I'm at man,
man.
You know what,
that shit was crazy
story is the same as yours almost.
It's,
it's slightly different in that I did it
the first time I did it.
I was pretty fucking profound,
intensely profound and I thought I'd hit
the center of the universe.
I thought I'd.
And then the second I did it,
I blew way past that spot to some
complete new place where there was no
avoiding it,
no denying it.
And I went,
oh this is it.
And then that's the spot I've been kinda
going to pretty much every time since
then.
But the first time was unbelievably
profound.
Way more profound than anything else and
I didn't really even get all the way
through me.
I didn't,
I haven't been through yet.
Like that world that you're talking
about.
Like I haven't went,
like I couldn't even get out of whatever
was happening in that room in my house
because it was.
I don't know if I want to keep your eyes
open.
I,
for the most part,
my eyes were wide open because I was so
intrigued that like,
yeah,
I've seen a bunch of shit around you.
Yeah.
But then when I closed my eyes and I got
over that,
then I was a whole nother experience and
that was this tunnel like thing and then
it was dark.
It was more,
some evil shit happen in there.
It didn't freak me out too much.
But you know,
because I know like that's another thing
people like as long as you,
if you see some shit that might freak
you out,
this remember you are on drugs,
you know,
lIke some shit,
you know or you're seeing demons for
real.
Yeah.
But they can't harm you,
you know,
just sit your ass still don't fucking
move and you'll come back hopefully.
Hopefully.
But this was more just like some,
some weird shit happened and I didn't go
down that rabbit hole too far.
I'm just kind of opened my eyes back
open and just kinda still shit was
weird.
But I kid you not joe,
as soon as I was kinda like I'm all
right,
I'm over this.
Then I came back and it was kinda like,
well,
I could describe as like an overlapping
a little bit of that world in reality.
Still a little haze of it where there
was shades of the other world.
It was almost like I saw a face in the
corner of my room,
just kind of dipped back off until the
walls.
Yeah.
I saw like these kinda like spidery
things kind of coming out and my grammy
and onto the ground.
But that's the thing though at this
point in my room was back to being it
being a room,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I was back to reality,
but it was like this,
this,
you know,
the world was still.
It's like,
uh,
the echo from where I was at was still
kind of in the room,
you know,
and it hasn't worn off yet.
Yeah.
Well next time you do it,
don't do it that way.
We do it.
Just keep your eyes closed and let it
go.
Don't keep my eyes open.
No,
I don't think so.
Keeping the eyes open part is,
uh,
probably fucking with you.
Oh man,
I was,
you know,
they say the best way to do it isn't a
really comfortable.
I mean I loved it though.
It was,
it wasn't absolutely positive,
but I didn't go to,
I didn't go to that world that you,
you said you were going to because my
eyes were open.
It was really just,
I was just so intriguing.
I wanted to spend crazy when I got done
I wanted to paint everything I saw
because I just had never seen that like
that and I never want to paint.
Do
alex grey's paintings.
Yes.
And that's the thing,
but I don't know if it was my shit was
going to be like that because I didn't
go to that world.
Right,
right,
right.
But just whatever you went to,
it'd be different.
But like,
you know how you were saying like,
or some of those paintings are just like
some guy and it's like all this energy
around it and so on.
These colors.
I didn't see that.
I didn't get to yet.
You probably.
Yeah.
Well most people don't get enough,
you know,
let's just put it.
Like I said,
my first experience,
I thought it was pretty fucking amazing
and it still wasn't nothing like the
second one,
the second one,
I was like,
oh,
I get it.
That was rIdiculous.
I thought I was already there because
what I'd seen was still so much
different than reality.
I was like,
wow,
this is the craziest thing ever.
But it was not even close to the actual
craziest thing.
So you close your eyes every time.
Yeah.
Never have opened my eyes before.
And what happened?
She patterns everywhere.
It's like it's too much.
I think there's the conflict of
information.
There's the information you're getting
from your eyeballs.
There's two different trips.
Yeah,
and then there's what's going on in your
imagination or your mind,
whatever the imagination is not even to
imply that it's not real or it's not a
real experience that imagined the term
imagination is a lot of negative
connotations to it,
but whatever it's going on,
when you got your eyes closed,
you're not.
There's no physical objects in front of
you.
You've seen all this stuff happening in
your,
in your visual field with your eyes
closed,
but you're not,
you know,
there's,
there's nothing you reach out and grab.
So that's why I'm saying imagination,
but whatever you're doing when you're
doing that is real and I don't know what
it is that I don't know what the fuck is
happening,
but it's real.
Do we're out of time.
Oh man,
it's over.
We did three hours dissolve by.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
And I think it was cool for people to
get a unique insight into your creative
process and that was really powerful.
All the shit that you shared about your
personal life and the coke and
everything.
That was amazing,
man.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So yeah,
anytime.
And a ladies and gentlemen,
that's the end.
He dirty fox.
So,
uh,
we will see you very soon.
Many more podcasts this week and until
then,
go fuck yourselves.
You guys much love to everybody.
Big kiss.
That was awesome.
We definitely.